I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, everyone. Hi, you guys.
我是珍娜·费舍（Jenna Fischer），我是安吉拉·金西（Angela Kinsey）。我们一起演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有两个亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士们。大家好。嗨，各位。
I hope you're having a great day. Today we're going to talk about Gossip. It is the season premiere of season six. Holy moly. We're at season six. Yeah. We're going down the other side of the mountain. We hit the peak at 100 episodes.
希望你们今天过得愉快。今天我们要聊聊《八卦》。这是第六季的首播集。天哪。我们已经到第六季了。是啊。我们开始翻过这座山的另一面了。我们在100集时达到了顶峰。
Now we've got 104. Downhill all the way. No, that's not how I met that metaphor to be. I just meant we're halfway to our destination. We're halfway there. Oh. No. Oh, and now I heard it.
现在我们已经104集了。一路下坡。不，我不是那个意思。我只是说我们离目的地已经过半了。我们已经走了一半了。哦。不。哦，现在我听懂了。
Woo-go, woo-go, woo-go. No. OK, I'll just stop. Oh, I'm liking this. Listen, this episode was written by Paul Lieberstein and directed by Paul Lieberstein, and here is your summary. When Michael regretfully reveals that Stanley is having an affair, he sets out to cover his tracks by spreading a bunch of lies about basically everyone in the office.
呜——走，呜——走，呜——走。不。好吧，我还是闭嘴吧。哦，我喜欢这个。听着，这一集由保罗·利伯斯坦（Paul Lieberstein）编剧并执导，以下是剧情梗概。当迈克尔遗憾地透露斯坦利有婚外情时，他开始通过在办公室里散布关于几乎所有人的谎言来掩盖自己的行踪。
But what he doesn't realize is that one of his lies turns out to be true. Before we get started on the fast facts, Angela, we have some gossip. Or maybe it's not gossip. Maybe it's true. Maybe it's the one true thing. OK, it's totally real. It's not gossip. Guys, our book cover for Office BFFs is out.
但他没有意识到的是，他的一个谎言竟然成真了。在我们开始快讯之前，安吉拉，我们有一些八卦。或者也许这不是八卦。也许它是真的。也许它是唯一真实的。好吧，这完全是真的。这不是八卦。伙计们，我们的《办公室闺蜜》书封出来了。
It is out. It's official. Right now. You can see it. It's so cute. Can I say that? I can say it's cute, right? I hope we think it's cute.
出来了。官方的。就在现在。你们可以看到了。太可爱了。我能这么说吗？我说它可爱是可以的，对吧？我希望我们都觉得它可爱。
We picked it. We picked it. You guys, I think you know this about me by now. I love a photo booth. This is true. If I walk by a photo booth with you, you're going in it with me. And Jen and I went to a photo booth at the mall one day. This was years ago.
我们选的。我们选的。伙计们，我想你们现在对我有所了解了。我喜欢大头贴拍照亭。这是真的。如果我和你路过一个拍照亭，你一定会跟我一起进去。我和珍娜有一天在商场的拍照亭拍了照片。那是几年前的事了。
Years ago. Ten years ago, maybe. Oh, was it more than that? Maybe more. I saved the photo strip from this mall photo booth. It's been on my bulletin board for a number of years, and it's the photo of our book cover. I'm realizing now that we chose a 15-year-old photo for a book cover, probably because we didn't want to pose for a photo.
几年前。也许十年前。哦，还不止吗？也许更多。我把商场拍照亭的照片条保存了下来。它在我的公告板上挂了好几年了，这就是我们书封上的照片。我现在才意识到，我们为书封选了一张15年前的照片，可能是因为我们不想专门去摆姿势拍照吧。
But actually, the point of it was to show the depth of our friendship, the length of our friendship, because so much of the book is going over the growth and history of our friendship. It is, you guys. It is our life through the Office and beyond, Best Friendship Journal, with the backdrop of this amazing show and just a lot of our stories that we can't get into as much in the podcast are in the book. Also in the book are 400 of our personal photos.
但实际上，这首歌的重点是展示我们友谊的深度、友谊的长度，因为这本书很大一部分都在回顾我们友谊的发展和历史。是的，伙计们。这是我们通过《办公室》及其他经历串联起来的人生，是最佳友谊日志，背景是这部精彩的剧集，书里还有很多我们在播客中无法深入探讨的故事。书中还有400张我们的个人照片。
Can I just take a minute? 400, that was so hard to narrow down, because we had like 2,000, and they were like, you guys, your book cannot have 2,000 pictures. They told us we had to narrow it down to like 200, Jen and I were like, we got it to 400. Can we call it even? So these are truly our personal photos taken on our personal cameras even back then when you had the old-timey cameras with film. Yes, and you had to go to the mall to the kiosk.
能让我花一分钟时间吗？400张，精简起来太难了，因为我们大约有2000张，他们说，你们好，你们的书不能有2000张照片。他们告诉我们必须精简到200张左右，珍娜和我当时就说，我们弄了400张。我们能折中一下吗？所以这些绝对是我们的个人照片，是用我们当时的个人相机拍的，甚至是那种还有胶卷的老式相机。是的，你还得去商场的小亭子。
Yep. Those pictures, all the way back to the pilot of the office. The book is available for pre-order now. We would appreciate it if you pre-order it, because it makes us look really good to our publishers. I wish you could see Jenna's face right now, because she's doing that really cute face that your kids do when they really want something at Christmas. So yeah, pre-order would be amazing.
没错。这些照片，一直追溯到《办公室》试播集。这本书现在可以预订了。如果你能预订的话，我们会非常感激，因为这在我们的出版商面前让我们看起来很棒。我希望你们现在能看到珍娜的表情，因为她正在做那种你孩子们在圣诞节非常想要某样东西时会做出的超级可爱的表情。所以，是的，预订会太棒了。
Thank you in advance. I know that Midwesterner and me gets very shy asking people to do things like that, but you can find a link to order the book on OfficeLadies.com. We will of course put it on all of our social media platforms as well. Yes. So check out the cover. Office BFFs, check it out. We can't wait to share this book with you.
提前谢谢大家。我知道我身上那股中西部人的性格，在要求别人做这种事时会非常害羞，但你可以在 OfficeLadies.com 上找到订购这本书的链接。我们当然也会把它发布到我们所有的社交媒体平台上。是的。所以去看看封面吧。《办公室闺蜜》，快去看看。我们迫不及待地想与大家分享这本书了。
We're super excited to take it out in the world and meet you all and sign copies and do a whole shebang. And I will wear a fake flower. You mark my words. I don't doubt it for a second. Should we get back to the episode? Let's do it. Fast fact number one, Gossip, as I said, was our season six premiere episode.
我们超级兴奋能把它带到世界上，与大家见面，签名并举办整套活动。我还要戴一朵假花。你们等着瞧吧。我一点也不怀疑。我们要回到这一集吗？开始吧。快讯第一条，《八卦》正如我所说，是我们的第六季首播集。
It aired on September 17, 2009, and it was seen by 8.21 million viewers. Wow. That seems like a lot. It was a lot, however, our viewership was down 18% compared to the season five premiere of Weight Loss. Oh. So I guess we took a little dip here with our premiere episode, but the office was still the leading comedy on NBC at the time, and we were sort of the anchor for the other shows.
它于2009年9月17日播出，收视观众达到821万。哇。听起来好多。确实很多，不过，与第五季首播集《减肥》相比，我们的收视率下降了18%。哦。所以我想我们的首播集收视率有点下滑，但《办公室》当时仍然是NBC的王牌喜剧，我们算是其他节目的顶梁柱。
I found an old promo. Oh, I love an old promo. That was kicking off the whole like fall season, and the office was very prominent in it. Will you guys play it? Here's why summer being over is a good thing, because now we get new comedy on NBC Thursday. That's cool. We'll finally confirm the big baby news on the office, and we welcome back Parks and Rec, 30 Rock and SNL in prime time, plus the new comedy community, a perfect fit on Thursdays.
我找到了一段老宣传片。哦，我喜欢老宣传片。那是为整个秋季档拉开序幕的，而《办公室》在其中非常显眼。你们能播放一下吗？这就是为什么夏天结束是一件好事，因为现在我们可以在周四观看NBC的新喜剧了。太棒了。我们终于将在《办公室》中证实那个重大的婴儿新闻，我们欢迎《公园与游憩》、《我本疯狂》和《周六夜现场》在黄金时段回归，此外还有新喜剧《废柴联盟》，它们完美契合了周四档。
You ready, Amiga? Let's see. And it always ends with Jay. All your favorite comedies are back on One Great Night, Thursday, September 17th on NBC. Oh, man, I miss those promo guys. Those guys, they crack me up every time they're like, all your favorites in one place. Yeah.
准备好了吗，朋友？我们来看看。它总是以杰伊结尾。你所有喜爱的喜剧都在一个伟大的夜晚回归，9月17日星期四在NBC播出。天哪，我想念那些宣传片配音员了。那些家伙，每次他们说“你所有喜爱的节目都在一个地方”时，都让我忍俊不禁。是啊。
They kind of do a breathy thing. Well, when I saw this promo, it made me think of something. What? Well, they say summer is over. You know, we're back. Yeah, yeah. Why did the documentary film crew stop filming us every summer? There's always a time jump, lady, because they're a fakie film crew.
他们听起来有点气喘吁吁的。嗯，当我看到这个宣传片时，让我想起了一件事。什么事？嗯，他们说夏天结束了。你知道，我们回来了。是啊，是啊。为什么纪录片摄制组每年夏天都停止拍摄我们？每次都有时间跳跃，女士们，因为他们是假摄制组。
I mean, why not film us in the summer? We jump ahead in time. It's been several weeks since Pam and Jim got their pregnancy news. And now, you know, she's quite far along by this episode. I just, I'm like, why? Why did they, why did they take a break? All right, fast fact number two, Gossip was the first episode to feature Ellie Kemper as a full cast member.
我是说，为什么不夏天也拍我们呢？我们直接跳到了未来。距离吉姆和帕姆得知怀孕消息已经过去好几周了。现在，你知道，到这一集时她的肚子已经很大了。我只是在想，为什么？为什么他们要休息？好的，快讯第二条，《八卦》是埃里·坎珀（Ellie Kemper）作为全职演员参演的第一集。
It was also the first episode of The Office to air since the release of The Hangover, starring our very own Ed Helms. This movie was a huge hit. Yeah. Huge. If you don't know it, it's the story of these three guys who go to Vegas for a bachelor party, but they lose the groom and they wake up from this night of intense partying. The groom is gone and they have to retrace their steps and try to find him.
这也是《办公室》自电影《宿醉》上映以来播出的第一集，该片由我们自己的埃德·海姆斯（Ed Helms）主演。这部电影大获成功。是的。巨大成功。如果你不知道，那是三个单身汉去维加斯参加单身派对的故事，但他们弄丢了新郎，并在疯狂派对的一夜后醒来。新郎不见了，他们必须循着原路回去试图找到他。
And Ed was one of the stars. This movie made $469 million at the box office. What the heck? Bradley Cooper, Zach Galifianakis, Ed Helms became superstars. Ken Zhang was in this movie, Superstar. I went to the Hangover DVD release party in Las Vegas with Rachel Harris. You didn't. I did.
埃德是主演之一。这部电影在票房上赚了4.69亿美元。搞什么鬼？布莱德利·库珀、扎克·加利费安纳基斯、埃德·海姆斯都成了巨星。郑肯也演了这部电影，巨星。我和瑞秋·哈里斯（Rachel Harris）一起去了拉斯维加斯的《宿醉》DVD发行派对。你才没有。我真的去了。
Rachel. Because Rachel Harris was in the movie. Yes. She played Ed's girlfriend, the sort of persnickety girlfriend. I witnessed her plus one and lady, guess where this big party was in Vegas? I don't know. Caesar's Palace. Oh, of course, because the movie.
瑞秋。因为瑞秋·哈里斯演了那部电影。是的。她演埃德的女朋友，那个有点挑剔的女朋友。我亲眼见证了她带男伴出席，女士，你猜这个盛大的派对在维加斯的什么地方？我不知道。凯撒宫。哦，当然，因为那部电影。
Club Pure. I found some red carpet photos. No, you did not. I did this evening and I cannot wait to show them to you. Who? Angela. Angela has on boots that go up to her knees. Black leather go-go boots.
纯粹俱乐部。我找到了一些红毯照片。不，你没有。我今天傍晚拍的，我迫不及待想给你们看。谁？安吉拉。安吉拉穿着一双及膝靴。黑色皮革果戈里靴。
Oh, wow. Look at you. I was in Vegas. You got to like bring out your boots for Vegas. So yeah, I went to the Hangover DVD release party. Well, we want you guys to know that Ed was a horrible person after he became a big star. No, he wasn't. He was just even more Ed.
哦，哇。瞧瞧你。我在维加斯。去维加斯你得把靴子拿出来穿。所以，是的，我去了《宿醉》DVD发行派对。嗯，我们希望你们知道，埃德在大红大紫之后变成了一个糟糕的人。不，他才没有。他只是变得更像埃德了。
He never changed. What a sweet guy. We were so happy for this big success. Yeah. He went on to make more Hangover movies and more movies. And develop TV series, but he's still the same old Ed. He is. Fast fact number three, I have titled, What did you do over that summer?
他从未改变。真是个贴心的人。我们为他的巨大成功感到高兴。是的。他接着拍了更多的《宿醉》电影和更多的电影。并开发了电视剧，但他仍然是以前那个老埃德。他确实是。快讯第三条，我给它取名为：那个夏天你做了什么？
Hmm. Because I was like, this was like a life altering summer for Ed Helms. Yeah. A life altering summer for Ellie Kemper, because she was made a regular on this TV show. I realized I had a life altering summer as well. What'd you do? Two very big things happened to me over this summer. The first thing that happened was that my beloved Andi cat, you know, the one that was
嗯。因为我觉得，这对埃德·海姆斯来说是一个改变人生的夏天。是的。对埃里·坎珀来说也是一个改变人生的夏天，因为她成了这部电视剧的常驻演员。我意识到我也度过了一个改变人生的夏天。你做了什么？那个夏天发生了两件对我来说非常大的事。第一件发生的事情是，我挚爱的安迪猫，你知道的，就是那只
in the People magazine shoot with me, the one that you had a voice for, you would talk as Andi. Yes, I would. We haven't shared about that. Oh, sorry. We haven't. That's okay. The one who knows me going all the way back to college knows I had a little voice for
跟我一起上过《人物》杂志拍摄的猫，就是你曾为它配音、用安迪的声音说话的那只。是的，我做过。我们还没分享过这个呢。哦，抱歉。我们还没有。没关系。了解我、甚至一路了解我到大学的人都知道我曾为
Andi. I'll have you know, Sonny has one as well. Oh, yeah. All of your animals have their own unique accents. They do. Because by the way, I think Andi's name was Andi, but he pronounced it Andi. Yeah. That was a choice he made.
安迪模仿过一个小声音。我不妨告诉你，桑尼也有一个。哦，是的。你所有的动物都有它们自己独特的口音。它们确实有。因为顺便说一句，安迪的名字叫安迪，但他把它发音成安迪。是的。那是他做出的选择。
Right. So anyway, sweet Andi passed away over this summer. He was almost 17 years old, but that was a big thing for me because he had traveled with me all the way from Kirksville, Missouri, all the way to Hollywood, and he was my love. I know. Really and truly. So also that summer though, Angela Lee proposed to me. Oh my gosh.
好。总之，可爱的安迪在那个夏天去世了。他快17岁了，但这对我很重要，因为他一路陪着我从密苏里州柯克斯维尔一直来到好莱坞，他就是我的挚爱。我知道。真的。所以也是在那个夏天，李（Lee）向我求婚了。哦，天哪。
That's right. Yes. We were in Paris, Paris, Paris, Paris. And he proposed by the river. We were having a little picnic with wine and cheese. What the heck is this? It's so Parisian. Well, then it got even more rom-com because Lee and I were like, oh, maybe we keep the
没错。是的。我们在巴黎，巴黎，巴黎，巴黎。他在河边向我们求婚。我们在那里喝着红酒、吃着奶酪进行了一次小野餐。这到底是什么鬼？太巴黎了。嗯，然后它变得更像是浪漫喜剧了，因为我和李觉得，哦，也许我们可以把
engagement to ourselves for a little while. I mean, we told all of our close friends, we told our family, but we thought like maybe we don't go public with the news for a while. I don't know. Yeah, yeah. Just keeping things private. Well, someone in this little Parisian restaurant overheard us telling another couple that we had gotten engaged.
订婚的消息自己留一会儿。我是说，我们告诉了我们所有的挚友，我们告诉了家人，但我们觉得也许我们暂时不把这个消息公之于众。我不知道。是的，是的。只是保持隐私。好吧，那个巴黎小餐厅里的某个人无意中听到我们告诉另一对夫妇我们订婚了。
So while we're flying back home, it hit the news. I mean, talk about gossip. Oh my gosh, this is so on theme. You were gossip. All the gossip magazines, we land to like this crazy amount of emails and texts. We were on like entertainment tonight. Oh my gosh. My extended family is calling me.
所以当我们飞回家的途中，这个消息就上了新闻。我是说，谈到八卦。哦，天哪，这太应景了。你就是八卦。所有的八卦杂志，我们落地时看到铺天盖地的邮件和短信。我们甚至上了《今夜娱乐》。哦，天哪。我的远亲都在给我打电话。
It was so bonkers. But yeah, it was a big summer. Well, my story isn't that great. Oh no, I'm so sorry if I like, I was like, we're going to share what we did that summer. Well, I guess I didn't give it the content. You didn't tell me what you were going to share. Well, oddly enough, I also spent part of that summer with Ken Jeong. Oh my gosh.
太疯狂了。不过，是的，那是个伟大的夏天。嗯，我的故事没那么棒。哦不，我很抱歉，如果我好像在说，我们要分享那个夏天我们做了什么。好吧，我想我没有给出内容。你没有告诉我你要分享什么。嗯，说来也巧，我也有一部分夏天是和郑肯一起度过的。哦，天哪。
This is when we did that movie, Furry Vengeance. Oh yes. Yes, where I play his, you know, sidekick. We had so much fun. You shared about your crazy adventure for his birthday, walking to P.F. Chang's. Yeah, exactly. But you know, we filmed outside of Boston and I'd never spent a lot of time in that city and I just fell in love with it.
这是我们拍那部电影《毛茸茸的复仇》的时候。哦，是的。是的，我在片中演他的，你知道的，助手。我们玩得太开心了。你分享了你为他的生日进行的那次疯狂冒险，步行去P.F. Chang's餐厅。是的，完全没错。但你知道，我们在波士顿郊外拍摄，我以前从未在那座城市花太多时间，我简直爱上了它。
Two things that I remember that I loved is that I took my daughter to the Boston Children's Museum. It was so fun. They have so many cool interactive things in this children's museum. And there was also a tall ship festival. Tall ship? Yes. You know, they were like ye olde ships, you know, that like the explorers had that like
我记得并深爱的两件事是，我带女儿去了波士顿儿童博物馆。太有趣了。这个儿童博物馆里有那么多酷炫的互动项目。还有一个高船节。高船？是的。你知道，它们就像是那些古老的船只，你知道的，就像
people came over when they're like, is the world round or flat? Yes, ships. Yes, like the Mayflower, those looking like ships. Right. And there were antiques. You know what I mean? Wow. But they're, they call them the tall ships because they have those really, really, really
探险家们曾乘坐的那种，当人们还在争论“世界是圆的还是平的”时乘着跨海而来的船。是的，船。是的，就像五月花号那种外型的船。没错。而且还有古董。你知道我的意思吗？哇。
tall mass, right? Okay. For the sales. And there were like 45 of them in the harbor. 45. Mm-hmm. And they do this transatlantic regatta. It begins in Spain, continues to Halifax, Canada from Boston before finishing in Ireland.
但人们把它们叫做高船，因为它们有那些非常、非常、非常高的桅杆，对吧？好吧。为了挂风帆。海港里大约有45艘这样的船。45艘。嗯哼。他们还进行跨大西洋帆船赛。比赛从西班牙开始，经加拿大哈利法克斯，从波士顿出发，最后在爱尔兰结束。
On the ye olde ships? Yes. They still sail? Yes. Are they replicas? Are they oldie ships? Well, I don't know, Jenna. Well, I mean, I just think they could be real oldie ships because I mean, the way they
乘着那些古老的船？是的。它们现在还能航行？是的。它们是复制品吗？还是老旧的古董船？嗯，我不知道，珍娜。好吧，我是说，我只是觉得它们可能是真正的古董船，因为我是说，以它们
built those, I've read books. Yeah. Do you like that? I have read books. I have read books. Maybe they're replicas, but I will tell you that it was 16 countries represented in about 1800 cadets. Wow.
建造的方式，我读过书。是吗？你喜欢这样？我读过书。我读过书。也许它们是复制品，但我可以告诉你的是，有16个国家参与，大约有1800名学员。哇。
So yeah, tall ships. Boston Harbor, I made Ken walk around and look at him with me. I have a picture somewhere of me and him standing next to one. That's one of my favorite things about our job are the places I get to go and the things I get to experience that I wouldn't normally get to experience. You know, growing up in the middle of the country, I was never close to an ocean. You know, I didn't see the ocean until I don't even know when. I think we did like a road trip to the Gulf of Mexico one year.
所以，是的，高船。波士顿港，我拉着郑肯四处走动，陪我看它们。我某处有一张我和他站在一艘船旁边的照片。关于我们的工作，我最喜欢的一点就是我能去的地方以及我能体验到的事情，这些是我通常无法体验到的。你知道，在一个国家的中部长大，我从来没有靠近过海洋。你知道，直到我甚至不知道什么时候我才第一次看到海。我想我们有一年还开车去过墨西哥湾。
It was just like, I don't know. Sometimes I just pinch myself when I think about all the stuff I get to see and do because of our job. Oh, so cool. Tall ships. Tall ships. Me and Ken walking around tall ships. You know what?
当时我就觉得，我不知道。有时当我想到因为我们的工作而看到和经历的所有事情时，我就会掐自己一下。哦，太酷了。高船。高船。我和郑肯在到处看高船。你知道吗？
I think we should take a break. And when we come back, you and I should try some parkour. Oh boy. Yes. Okay. Parkour. I tried to put my foot up on the desk and it hurt my back, so I didn't do it. Parkour.
我想我们应该休息一下。当我们回来时，你和我应该尝试一些跑酷。哦，天哪。是的。好吧。跑酷。我试图把一只脚抬到桌子上，结果扭伤了背，所以我没做。跑酷。
Are you ready? Are you going to parkour? I'm going to parkour. Wait. Are you going to do something visual in a podcast? I'm going to do something visual. Not me. You?
准备好了吗？你要去跑酷吗？我要去跑酷。等等。你打算在一个播客节目里做一些视觉动作吗？我要做一个视觉动作。不是我。你？
I'm going to parkour. Okay. Let's do it. Don't really do it. Oh my God. Don't. Stop. Parkour.
我要跑酷。好吧。开始吧。别真的做。哦，天哪。别。停下。跑酷。
Oh my God. Oh God. Stop. Stop. Stop. You guys, she pushed off from the table and shook all the microphones, then she ran over to the wall and I want to say about two feet high, put her foot on the wall and jumped. I'm out of breath.
哦，天哪。哦，天哪。停下。停下。停下。伙计们，她从桌子上借力推开，把所有的麦克风都震动了，然后她跑到墙边，我想大概有两英尺高，把脚搭在墙上跳了一下。我上气不接下气了。
I'm out of breath. Well, Michael and Andy and Dwight are taking their parkour skills in the office to a much more destructive level than what Jenna just did. They're just jumping off everything. Jenna, do you remember the guys that literally wrecked the office? I do remember. Stuff went everywhere. Yeah.
我上气不接下气了。嗯，迈克尔、安迪和德怀特正在办公室里把他们的跑酷技能提升到一个比珍娜刚才做的更具破坏性的水平。他们只是从所有东西上往下跳。珍娜，你还记得那些把办公室彻底搞砸的家伙吗？我当然记得。东西到处都是。是啊。
You know, we had a fan question from Alice R. in Italy. How much of the parkour scene was scripted and choreographed? Well, I reached out to Paul Lieberstein who wrote and directed this episode because in the script, it really just says they parkour through the office and he said that the direction he gave Steve, Rain and Ed was just a basic route to move through so that the camera could capture all of them. He said, obviously, none of them had any parkour skills. They did no parkour training whatsoever.
你知道，我们有一个来自意大利爱丽丝·R的粉丝提问。跑酷那场戏有多少是按剧本和编排好的？嗯，我联系了编剧兼导演这一集的保罗·利伯斯坦，因为在剧本里，真的只是写着他们在办公室里跑酷，他说他给史蒂夫、雷恩和埃德的指导只是一条穿过房间的基本路线，以便摄像机能捕捉到他们所有人。他说，很显然，他们中没有一个人有任何跑酷技能。他们根本没有做过任何跑酷训练。
What? I'm shocked. It was not choreographed. He just told them, you can't do anything wrong and your goal is to just mess up the room as much as possible. Achieved. Yet, he said the first take was really kind of underwhelming. So they reset the office and he said on the next take, he told them all to shout parkour
什么？我惊呆了。这不是编排好的。他只是告诉他们，你们怎么做都不会错，你们的目标就是尽一切可能把房间弄得一团糟。大获成功。然而，他说第一条拍出来的效果确实有点不够震撼。所以他们重新整理了办公室，他说在拍下一条时，他告诉所有人一边跑一边大喊“跑酷”
as they went. So whenever they attempted to move, they were supposed to shout parkour. So they would do like a sloppy somersault off the back of a desk and go parkour. Yes. And he said that ended up being the thing that gave it this really kind of weird energy that was very funny. So yeah, I thought that was great actually because I thought a lot of the comedy came from the dichotomy between their very confident parkour and their horrible skills.
。所以每当他们试图移动时，他们都应该大喊“跑酷”。所以他们会从办公桌后面做一个笨拙的前滚翻，然后大喊“跑酷”。是的。他说，最后这成了让整个场面带有一种非常奇怪的能量并且非常搞笑的关键。所以，是的，我觉得这其实很棒，因为我觉得很多喜剧效果来自于他们非常自信的跑酷与他们糟糕的技能之间的巨大反差。
Well, Jim has a great talking head that sort of explains what's happening. And he's like, you know, this was this internet sensation of 2004, it was in one of the Bond films. Lady, I think it was in Casino Royale. Hear me out. I love Daniel Craig. Yeah, same. And he had this great scene with actor named Sebastian Focon.
嗯，吉姆有一段很棒的“镜头前独白”，解释了发生了什么。他说，你知道，这是2004年的一股互联网风潮，它出现在其中一部邦德电影里。女士，我认为它出现在《大战皇家赌场》中。听我说完。我喜欢丹尼尔·克雷格。是的，我也是。他和一位名叫塞巴斯蒂安·福康（Sebastian Focon）的演员有一场非常棒的对手戏。
Okay. And I mean, it was so cool. Talk about a choreographed fight scene. Well, isn't so much of the matrix kind of rooted in parkour? Am I crazy? What part? What part? They're leaping all over stuff.
好的。我是说，太酷了。谈谈编排好的打斗场面。嗯，《黑客帝国》很大程度上不也是根植于跑酷吗？我是疯了吗？哪部分？哪部分？他们在各种东西上跳来跳去。
No. Is it because in true parkour, you're really doing it. You don't have cables and stuff. Yeah. And you can't suspend time as a bullet goes past you. Right. That's not parkour. Well, I talked to Randy Cordray about this and he said that that video that Jim is playing,
不是的。是因为在真正的跑酷中，你是在实打实地做。你没有威亚之类的东西。是的。而且当一颗子弹从你身边飞过时，你无法让时间暂停。没错。那不是跑酷。嗯，我跟兰迪·科德瑞（Randy Cordray）聊过这个，他说吉姆正在播放的那段视频，
that was a clip of an actual amateur filmmaker student from UCLA doing parkour. They licensed it for $300. And then we had a new graphic artist for Seves and Six named Ryan Cosgrove, and he built a fakey YouTube-esque computer background. And so that's what you're seeing. He built that video into like a fakey video player. Nice. And that's what plays on Jim's computer.
其实是加州大学洛杉矶分校（UCLA）的一名业余学生电影制作人做跑酷的片段。他们花300美元买下了版权。然后我们第六季来了一位新的平面设计师叫瑞安·科斯格罗夫（Ryan Cosgrove），他制作了一个山寨版的YouTube风格电脑背景。所以这就是你们看到的。他把那个视频嵌入到一个山寨的视频播放器里。太棒了。这就是在吉姆的电脑上播放的内容。
I think that kind of stuff is so cool. I clocked a bunch of props in this episode. I feel like Phil Shea was busy in the cold open alone. We have the Apple laptop that Jim is using. We have the handheld camcorders that Michael Dwight and Andy are using. Meredith's deodorant spray, a wooden ladder, boxes, wooden pallets, dumpster, trash bins and the parking lot. And then as we get into the episode, there's so many more.
我觉得这种东西太酷了。我在这一集里记下了很多道具。我觉得光是在片头冷幽默里，菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea）就已经够忙了。我们有吉姆用的苹果笔记本电脑。我们有迈克尔、德怀特和安迪用的手持摄像机。梅雷迪思的除臭喷雾，一把木梯，纸箱，木托盘，垃圾箱，停车场里的垃圾桶。然后随着剧情深入，还有更多。
Well, you mentioned that handheld camera. We had a question from Chris W. in Liverpool, England, who wanted to know if that camera was actually recording. Yes, it was recording. When Phil Shea bought that camera, he first consulted with our cinematographer Matt Sohn and he got a broadcast acceptable, I guess, format for this camera. It was 1080 progressive at 24 frames per second. So anything they recorded on that camera was suitable for broadcast.
嗯，你提到了那个手持摄像机。我们收到了来自英国利物浦的克里斯·W的提问，他想知道那个摄像机当时是否真的在录像。是的，当时确实在录像。菲尔·谢伊买下那台摄像机时，他首先咨询了我们的摄影师马特·索恩（Matt Sohn），并且他为这款摄像机选了一个广播级格式，我想是的。那是1080逐行扫描，每秒24帧。所以他们在那台摄像机上录制的任何内容都适合广播播出。
1080p. 1080p. Yeah, I see that on my TV sometimes. Yeah. Right. Right. That's what that is. Okay.
1080p。1080p。是的，我有时在电视上看到这个。是的。没错。那就是那个。好吧。
Ultimately, we only used two images from that camera. One was at 1 minute 10 seconds, which is a close-up of Ed Helms when he's on top of the Vance refrigeration truck. And then one at 1 minute 14 seconds, showing the back of quote unquote Andy as he jumps off the truck. So good. These are the little details I love. I love that that camera was actually recording it.
最终，我们只用了那台摄像机拍摄的两个画面。一个是1分10秒处，那是埃德·海姆斯站在万斯冷藏卡车顶上的特写。另一个是1分14秒处，展示了所谓的安迪跳下卡车时的背面。太棒了。这就是我喜欢的小细节。我喜欢那台摄像机当时真的在录像。
They use some of the footage. I know. I had more fan questions on this parkour opening, Ange. Leah B. from Raleigh, North Carolina said, Hi, office ladies, I'm Leah B. and I'm 11. I've watched the office series three times and I was just wondering, did Ed Helms get a stunt double for the shot where he jumps off the delivery truck and lands in the refrigerator box? Was there padding in the box and how many shots did they do in order to get this scene?
他们还用了其中的一些素材。我知道。关于这个跑酷开场，我还有更多的粉丝提问，安吉。来自北卡罗来纳州罗利市的莉亚·B（Leah B.）说：“嗨，办公室女士们，我是莉亚·B，我11岁。我已经把《办公室》系列刷了三遍了，我只是想知道，埃德·海姆斯在从送货卡车上跳下来落入冰箱纸箱的那个镜头中，是不是用了替身？箱子里有垫子吗？为了拍好这一幕，他们拍了多少个镜头？”
Well, there was most definitely a stunt double. There definitely was. Our stunt coordinator for this whole sequence of jumping off the truck, because that, by the way, was completely 100% planned and choreographed. Also just those three guys being on top of the truck was like a safety thing. There was like safety meeting. Oh, for sure. Our stunt coordinator was Wally Crowder and his son, Sean Crowder, was Ed's stunt double.
嗯，绝对是有特身演员的。绝对有。我们负责整个跳卡车序列的特技指导——顺便说一句，那完全是100%计划和编排好的。而且仅仅是那三个人站在卡车顶部也是一个安全问题。举行了安全会议。哦，肯定的。我们的特技指导是沃利·克劳德（Wally Crowder），他的儿子肖恩·克劳德（Sean Crowder）是埃德的特技替身。
Eric Solke was Michael's stunt double and Scott Lever was Dwight's double. But until they were up on that refrigerator truck, it was all our guys. Even that scene when they're running across the cars in the parking lot, those were our real guys. And in fact, I guess they dented some of the hoods of those cars. They had to be repaired. But it was Sean Crowder who jumps off that truck into the cardboard box. The box was full of foam rubber.
埃里克·索尔克（Eric Solke）是迈克尔的特技替身，斯科特·利弗（Scott Lever）是德怀特的替身。但直到他们爬上那个冷藏卡车之前，全都是我们自己的演员。甚至当他们在停车场飞奔穿过汽车的那场戏，也是我们的真演员。事实上，我猜他们还把其中一些车的引擎盖踩出了凹痕。还得修理。但跳下卡车落入纸箱里的确实是肖恩·克劳德。箱子里塞满了泡沫橡胶。
I guess they had enough supplies to do three takes. They only did two takes and they used the first one in editing. He nailed it. Nailed it. Leah, I love that question. I love always finding out the behind the scenes of how they did all the stunts. So thanks for sending that in. So listen, one more thing about parkour before we get into this episode.
我想他们有足够的物资拍三个镜头。他们只拍了两个镜头，剪辑时用了第一个。他一次成功。一次成功。莉亚，我喜欢这个问题。我总是喜欢了解他们是如何完成所有特技动作的幕后故事。所以谢谢你发来提问。所以听着，在进入这一集之前，关于跑酷还有最后一件事。
Paul reminded me that after we shot this cold open. Do you remember this? Our camera assistants Chris and Ed and some of the other crew guys would walk around the stage and shout parkour from time to time. Like when he told me that, I was like, oh, yes, I remember that. It would just be like parkour. I remember we all were doing it. Yeah.
保罗提醒我，在我们拍完这段冷幽默之后。你还记得这个吗？我们的摄影助理克里斯、埃德和其他一些剧组成员会时不时地在片场走来走动并大喊“跑酷”。就像他跟我说这件事时，我就想，哦，是的，我记得。他们就会像这样：“跑酷”。我记得我们所有人都在这么做。是的。
Like we would open the fridge and go parkour. Yeah. Okay. That's all my parkour stuff. I liked it. Well, this episode starts with a little bit of hazing. Yeah. We have interns, summer interns.
就像我们打开冰箱然后大喊“跑酷”。是的。好了，这就是我所有的跑酷内容。我喜欢它。嗯，这一集以一点点“恶作剧整蛊”开始。是的。我们有实习生，暑期实习生。
We didn't film them all summer, but here they are in their last day. Yeah. We're going to get them on their last day. Dwight asked them for a cup of water, which he then chugs and then says, okay, see the files behind Kevin's desk. I want you to put them all in random order and then come back for your next assignment concerning their order. Yeah.
我们并没有一整个夏天都拍他们，但这是他们在公司的最后一天。是的。我们要赶在他们最后一天整蛊他们。德怀特向他们要了一杯水，然后一饮而尽，接着说：“好吧，看到凯文桌子后面的文件了吗？我要你把它们全部打乱顺序，然后再来找我领取关于它们顺序的下一个任务。”是的。
Can I just tell you that this hazing continued throughout the episode, but it was deleted. Oh. Yes. As it continues, you see Ryan having them make a bunch of photo copies for him. One of the interns is like, you know, you're not supposed to talk to us. And then it cuts to Dwight saying, yes, I've been managing the interns since Ryan's incident. And then we find out that Ryan's incident is he had him go to the bank and get a couple hundred dollars in pennies and made them spread them all out on the conference room
我能告诉你这种整蛊在全剧里一直在继续，但被删减了吗？哦。是的。随着整蛊的继续，你会看到瑞安让他们为他复印一堆文件。其中一个实习生说：“你知道的，你本不该跟我们说话的。”然后切到德怀特说：“是的，自从瑞安出事后，实习生就归我管了。”然后我们发现瑞安出的事是，他让实习生去银行拿了几百美元的硬币，并让他们把硬币全撒在会议室的桌子上，让他们在里面找珍贵的旧硬币。然后德怀特就被派去管他们了。
table to have them search for rare old coins. So then Dwight gets put in charge of them. That feels like something Dwight would make them do actually. I know. Ryan's like, how is that any worse than what Dwight made them do? And here's what Dwight had them do. He set up an inter-office messaging system where if you had a message, he would write it on a note and then he would make the intern walk it over, let's say to Andy or to Phyllis.
这感觉确实像是德怀特会让他们做的事。我知道。瑞安说：“这比德怀特让他们做的事恶劣到哪里去了？”以下是德怀特让他们做的事：他建立了一个办公室内部消息系统，如果你有消息，他会把它写在一张纸条上，然后他会让实习生走路把纸条送过去，比如说送给安迪或者菲利斯。
And so these interns were just standing by waiting for Dwight to write a note that then they would have to walk over to whatever department. So there was a lot of intern hazing. It's deleted. It's on the DVDs. Well, I can give you an intern breakdown, an actor breakdown. So we have Maury, who is played by Kelly E. Miata. Angela, he was born the year I graduated from high school.
所以这些实习生就一直站在那里等德怀特写一张纸条，然后他们得把纸条走路送到各个部门。所以有很多关于实习生整蛊的内容。都被删了。在DVD里。嗯，我可以给你做一个实习生演员分析。我们有莫里（Maury），由凯利·E·米亚塔（Kelly E. Miata）饰演。安吉拉，他出生的那年我高中毕业。
Oh, well, there's that. He's now 30 years old. He's a youngin'. Yeah. I found that humbling. Well, Megan was played by Elvie Yost. She goes by just Elvie now. She has been in the TV series Resident Alien and Mildred Pierce.
哦，好吧，那倒也是。他现在30岁了。他还是个年轻人呢。是的。我觉得这让我挺谦卑的。嗯，梅根（Megan）由埃尔维·约斯特（Elvie Yost）饰演。她现在直接叫埃尔维。她曾出演过电视剧《外星居民》和《欲海情魔》。
And then Eric was played by Max Carver. Now, Max would go on to play a recurring role on Desperate Housewives as Preston Scavo. Oh, you love Desperate Housewives. Oh, yes. He was on with his twin brother. He has since been on the leftovers and the series Teen Wolf. When I saw him on Desperate Housewives, I was like, it's the intern. I know him.
然后埃里克（Eric）由马克斯·卡弗（Max Carver）饰演。后来，马克斯在《绝望的主妇》中饰演普雷斯顿·斯卡沃（Preston Scavo），这是一个常驻角色。哦，你喜欢《绝望的主妇》。哦，是的。他和他的双胞胎兄弟一起出演的。他后来还出演了《守望尘世》和电视剧《少狼》。当我在《绝望的主妇》里看到他时，我就想：这不是那个实习生吗！我认识他。
I like, was so geeky that I had a connection to someone on Desperate Housewives. So I slid into his DMs. Did you really? I did. And he was nice enough to send in some audio clips about what it was like to be an intern on our show. And of course, we had to ask, how did he get his job on the office? Here's what he had to say.
我当时就像个极客一样，觉得我和《绝望的主妇》里的某个人有联系。所以我私信了他。真的吗？真的。而且他非常友好地发来了一些音频剪辑，讲述了在我们剧组当实习生的感受。当然，我们不得不问：他是怎么得到《办公室》这份工作的？他是这么说的：
Hey, it's Max Carver here. I'm super happy to be on the show. I remember I went in for casting for the office and I really, I'd never had any experience with comedy at the time. I just, I just read it and thought, you know, let's go in and be an intern. And the casting process was fun. I remember Allison was so sweet and we just had a laugh. I read it a couple of times and then I was so excited.
嘿，我是马克斯·卡弗。我非常高兴能上这个节目。我记得我曾去《办公室》试镜，真的，我当时没有任何喜剧经验。我只是，我只是读了剧本，然后心想：好吧，去试一下演个实习生吧。试镜过程很有趣。我记得艾莉森非常可爱，我们聊得很开心。我读了几遍，然后超级兴奋。
I couldn't believe I got the job as one of the first jobs I ever got in Hollywood. I was well aware of the show and a huge fan of both the British version and the American version. So it was a dream come true. So Angela, when I hear his voice in that audio clip, that is exactly how I remember him on set. He was just kind and they were really sweet. All really nice.
我简直不敢相信自己得到了这份工作，这是我在好莱坞得到的第一批工作之一。我对这部剧有所了解，而且我是英版和美版的大粉丝。所以这真是梦想成真。所以安吉拉，当我在那个音频剪辑里听到他的声音时，那就是我记忆中他在片场的样子。他人很好，他们真的很可爱。都非常nice。
They were just young, nice, sweet folks. Well, I also asked him, did he have any memories from his time on set? Here's what he said. One of the memories I have from being on set is that everyone there is just an improv master. So it's, there's just not enough time on TV for all the amazing stuff that we saw. I think we probably shot an hour worth of content and unfortunately you only get to see 22 minutes.
他们只是年轻、友好、甜美的人。嗯，我还问了他，他对他那段片场时光有什么记忆吗？他是这么说的：
But at one point, I remember Dwight was lecturing us interns about an experience he had with the lobster, which is a lobster for the record. And I just, I could not keep a straight face. I don't think that scene ever made it to air just because every time the camera panned over to me, I was, I was, I just couldn't keep a straight face. But Dwight is so funny, rain, rain just knew exactly what would make me laugh. So at every take, he just turned it up another notch and another notch and another notch. I don't think he even cared if we got the scene, he just wanted to make me laugh.
我在片场的记忆之一就是，那里的每个人都是即兴表演大师。所以，电视上根本没有足够的时间播出我们看到的所有精彩内容。我想我们大概拍了一个小时的内容，不幸的是你只能看到22分钟。但有一点，我记得德怀特向我们实习生训话，讲了他和一只龙虾（lobster，特指拼错的词）的经历，顺便说一句，是一只龙虾（lobstah）。然后我，我简直无法保持严肃。我不认为那一幕最终播出了，因为每当镜头摇向我时，我，我就是无法保持严肃。但德怀特太搞笑了，雷恩，雷恩就是知道什么能把我逗笑。所以在每一次拍摄时，他都会把搞笑程度再提高一个档次，再提高一个档次，再提高一个档次。我猜他根本不在乎我们能不能拍完这场戏，他只是想把我逗笑。
So I will, I will never forget that. That scene is in the deleted scenes on the DVD and it's very funny. You know, Dwight is basically trying to impart his wisdom to the interns and he has a huge speech. I'm going to paraphrase it, but he's like, I'm going to tell you a story about a young salesman who went out to a restaurant and he ordered a lobster because he had never had lobster before and he mispronounced it and called it a lobster. And he goes on and on until the story.
所以我永远、永远不会忘记这一点。那场戏在DVD的删减片段里，非常搞笑。你知道，德怀特基本上是试图向实习生传授他的智慧，他有一大段台词。我大概概括一下，他说的是：我要给你们讲一个年轻推销员的故事，他去了一家餐厅，点了一只龙虾，因为他以前从没吃过龙虾，结果他发音错误，把龙虾叫成了“lobstah”。然后他滔滔不绝地讲着这个故事。
Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. That's amazing. Well, the last question I asked Max was, does he ever get recognized for being Eric turn Eric on the office in terms of being recognized? Yeah. You know, I think fans of the office are probably the most hardcore fans in the world. I've worked on a number of other shows, but the office is the one that keeps coming up
哦，天哪。哦，天哪。太棒了。嗯，我问马克斯的最后一个问题是：他是否曾因为在《办公室》里饰演实习生埃里克而被认出来？
and it's always people like, I know you. I know you. You're from season six episode one, which is just blows my mind, but it's fun to be a small part of that cannon. And yeah, people, people remind me about the reams of sheets and Alan thick. So thanks for that. Max, thank you so much for sending in these audio clips. You made my day.
关于被认出来这件事，是的。你知道，我觉得《办公室》的粉丝可能是世界上最硬核的粉丝。我参演过很多其他剧集，但《办公室》是那部总是被频繁提及的剧，总是有人说：“我认识你。我认识你。你是第六季第一集的那个谁。”这让我大开眼界，但能成为这部经典作品的一小部分真的很有趣。是的，人们会提醒我关于那一叠叠纸张和阿兰·西克（Alan Thicke）的事。所以谢谢你。马克斯，非常感谢你发来这些音频剪辑。你让我的一天都变得美好了。
That's great. Well, you know, Jenna, I read the shooting draft of this episode and the interns actually had some different names. Oh. Well, Maury, who is Maury, was actually spelled M-O-R-I. And then in the episode that aired, you'll see it quoted as M-A-U-R-I-E, but it was actually spelled M-O-R-I in the shooting draft. And then Megan's name was actually Maria and Eric was Eric.
太棒了。嗯，你知道吗，珍娜，我读了这一集的拍摄剧本，实习生其实有不同的名字。哦。嗯，莫里（Maury），就是莫里，其实拼作 M-O-R-I。然后在播出的剧集中，你会看到拼写是 M-A-U-R-I-E，但在拍摄剧本中其实拼作 M-O-R-I。然后梅根的名字其实叫玛丽亚（Maria），埃里克就是埃里克。
So all through the shooting draft, I was reading it and I kept being like, who's Maria? So the interns are going to spark some gossip. They are. And I have two background catches in this scene. We have Oscar Meredith and Kelly speculating about this relationship between Eric and Megan. If you go to two minutes, 34 seconds, I am calling this the green scene. Oh.
所以通读拍摄剧本时，我一直纳闷：玛丽亚是谁？所以实习生们要引发一些八卦了。他们会的。我在这个场景里有两个背景发现。我们有奥斯卡、梅雷迪思和凯利在猜测埃里克和梅根之间的关系。如果你拉到2分34秒，我把这叫做绿色场景。哦。
Because Kelly has on a green sweater, Meredith has on a green cardigan, Megan has on a green blouse, and there is a turquoise green lunch bag on the table. Oh. Green scene. Green scene. Green in the break room. Green in the break room. And then at two minutes, 34 seconds, Megan and Eric are at a file cabinet by this back
因为凯利穿着一件绿毛衣，梅雷迪思穿着一件绿色开衫，梅根穿着一件绿色衬衫，桌上还有一个青绿色的午餐袋。哦。绿色场景。绿色场景。茶水间里的绿色。然后在大约2分34秒，梅根和埃里克在凯利工位群隔断另一侧那个后门旁边的文件柜旁。是的。
door, sort of on the other side of the partition by Kelly's desk clump. Yes. That file cabinet has never been used. Are they using it for the first time? Groundbreaking moment, everyone. Wow. First time file cabinet usage. So what happens here is that people are speculating if Eric and Megan are going to get married.
那个文件柜从来没用过。他们是在第一次使用吗？各位，具有划时代意义的时刻。哇。文件柜的第一次使用。所以这里发生的事情是，大家都在猜测埃里克和梅根是不是要结婚了。
And if they are hooking up, right, and Michael starts to feel very proud because he introduced them. Wait, can I just say I have my favorite line of this whole entire episode in this scene? I can't believe it's in this scene because I have a favorite line and it's later. Okay, go on. Well, Kelly is like upset at the idea that they might get married before she would, right? Michael walks in and says, who's getting married? Pam says, nobody.
他们是不是在约会，对吧，然后迈克尔开始感到非常骄傲，因为是他把他们凑到一起的。等等，我能说我在这个场景里有整集里我最喜欢的台词吗？我不敢相信它竟然在这个场景里，因为我最喜欢的台词其实是在后面。好吧，你继续。嗯，凯利对他们可能会在她前面结婚这个想法感到很不高兴，对吧？迈克尔走进来问：“谁要结婚了？”帕姆说：“没有谁。”
And here's my favorite line. Phyllis says, if somebody doesn't tell me, I'm going to start screaming. Oh, that is good. I was just like, who's so sad and you know, they know he will. Ultimately Phyllis says, Michael, there's nothing really to know. It's just gossip. Well, of course, Michael is now going to tailspin that he's been left out. Yeah.
然后是我最喜欢的台词。菲利斯说：“要是没人告诉我，我就要开始尖叫了。”哦，那句太棒了。我当时就想：谁这么惨，你知道的，大家都知道他会说。最终菲利斯说：“迈克尔，其实没什么好知道的。这只是八卦。”嗯，当然，迈克尔现在开始陷入焦虑，觉得自己被排挤了。是的。
Other people know gossip. He didn't know. But before we move on to that, I have some background catches in the break room as well. Okay. Phyllis is called, what is everyone eating? Phyllis is having a salad. She's eating something with a fork. I am definitely eating a salad with a side of grapes.
别人都知道八卦。他却不知道。但在我们继续之前，我在茶水间里也有一些背景发现。好吧。菲利斯叫什么名字，大家都在吃什么？菲利斯在吃沙拉。她正在用叉子吃东西。我绝对是在吃沙拉配一把葡萄。
Oscars food is blocked, but I think it might be a sandwich. Meredith is eating yogurt. Stanley has a very substantial sandwich and chips and a Fuji water bottle with the label facing away from camera. You're obsessed. I'm obsessed. But the food I want you to concentrate on is John Krasinski's food. Did you screen grab it?
奥斯卡的食物被挡住了，但我猜可能是三明治。梅雷迪思在吃酸奶。斯坦利有一个非常实在的三明治和薯片，还有一个斐济（Fuji）矿泉水瓶，瓶身标签背对着镜头。你太着迷了。我太着迷了。但我让你注意的食物是约翰·卡拉辛斯基（John Krasinski）的食物。你截屏了吗？
When I first saw it, it looked like a container of shredded chicken. What? But it's not. There's no fork. So I really zoomed in and what it is, is it is a sandwich that he has picked out the middle of and left the crusts. It's like he ate it from the inside out. It is the weirdest thing.
我刚看到的时候，它看起来像一盒手撕鸡。什么？但并不是。没有叉子。所以我仔细放大看了一下，原来是一个三明治，他把中间掏空了，只留下了面包皮。就好像他是从内向外吃的一样。这简直是最诡异的事情了。
Are we finding out right now that Jim is actually the person that eats like a squirrel and not Angela Martin? I think so. But you know, for a scene like this, it would just say in the script, they're in the break room having lunch and Phil Shea would have to go around to all of us and ask us what we wanted to eat in the scene. And for me, depending on how close it was to actual lunch, I would either pick a substantial meal or something small.
我们现在才发现，其实像松鼠一样吃东西的人是吉姆，而不是安吉拉·马丁吗？我想是的。但你知道的，对于这样一场戏，剧本里只会写他们在休息室吃午饭，而菲尔·谢（Phil Shea）就得去找我们所有人，问我们在戏里想吃什么。对我来说，这取决于离真正的午餐有多近，我会选择一顿丰盛的饭或者吃点小东西。
So I'm eating a salad and some grapes. That is not a meal to me. So we must have shot this after lunch because I was like, you know what, I will have already eaten. Just give me something light. They were always very mindful that my character was a vegetarian. So I often would be eating fruit or a salad or some kind of veggies or chips or something. I'm going to need a picture of that Jim sandwich.
所以我吃的是沙拉和一些葡萄。对我来说这可算不上是一顿饭。所以我们肯定是午饭后拍的，因为当时我想，你知道吗，我已经吃过了。随便给我拿点清淡的就行。他们一直非常照顾我，记得我这个角色是个素食主义者。所以我经常会吃水果、沙拉、某种蔬菜、薯片之类的东西。我得拍一张那个吉姆三明治的照片。
Thank you very much. You've got to take a picture of it for me. I'll show you. It's so odd. We're going to now have a Pam and Jim talking head. Where basically what we're doing here is we are confirming that what you knew from the season finale episode that Pam is pregnant. But they're also going to let you know they have not told anyone in the office.
非常感谢。你得帮我拍张照片。我给你看。真是太奇怪了。我们接下来要拍一个帕姆和吉姆的“谈话头”（Talking Head）镜头。这里基本上我们要做的，就是确认你在季终集里就知道的那件事——帕姆怀孕了。但他们也要让你们知道，他们还没把这事告诉办公室里的任何人。
Yeah. I loved it when Jim was like, you know, the yakity yaks in this office, they'll have a field day. So this is true, but they're keeping it to themselves. That's what you need to know. Michael's determined to get to the bottom of this gossip. He goes to Dwight and Dwight knew all of it. Yeah.
对。我特别喜欢吉姆说的那句，你知道的，办公室里这些八卦精们，他们又要大做文章了。所以这是真的，但他们俩把它藏在心里。这就是你们需要知道的。迈克尔决心把这个八卦查个水落石出。他去找了德怀特，而德怀特什么都知道。对。
Oh, this is going to make Michael's spiral even more. He has this great talking head and Jenna, Steve could not get through this. The one about the poop ball. He couldn't get through it. And Steve rarely broke. Here's the blooper. It just makes me laugh hearing Steve and you hear Paul Leverstein laughing. I hate, hate, hate being left out, whether it's for a sport or like not being picked
哦，这会让迈克尔更加抓狂。他有一个非常棒的“谈话头”镜头，而且简娜，史蒂夫根本拍不下去。就是关于那个“屎球”的那段。他实在拍不下去。而且史蒂夫很少笑场。这段是NG花絮。听到史蒂夫笑，还有你能听到保罗·莱文斯坦（Paul Leverstein）在笑，就让我觉得很好笑。我讨厌、讨厌、讨厌被冷落，不管是参加体育运动，还是没被选进
for a team or being picked for a team and then showing up and realizing that the team doesn't exist or that the sport doesn't exist. I should have known poop ball. That's so great. They're like little kids. I know. They couldn't get through the word poop ball. I loved it every time Steve got tickled like that.
某个队伍，或者被选进了一个队伍，结果到了之后发现那个队伍根本不存在，或者说那个运动根本不存在。我早该想到的，“屎球”。太棒了。他们就像小孩子一样。我知道。他们就是过不了“屎球”这个词。我太喜欢史蒂夫每次被逗得咯咯笑的样子了。
Me too. Michael is now going to corner Maury in the kitchen. Maury is making coffee. He has to know about this rumor about Eric and Megan. So he's like, was it hard to be the third wheel on their group date and Maury is like, no. Michael's like, you know, my mom said the third wheel is what makes it a tricycle. Oh, my God.
我也是。迈克尔现在要把莫里逼到厨房的角落里。莫里正在煮咖啡。他必须弄清楚关于埃里克和梅根的这个谣言。所以他就问，当他们双人约会时的“电灯泡”是不是很难受？而莫里说，不难受。迈克尔就说，你知道的，我妈妈说过，“电灯泡”才是让三轮车转起来的关键。哦，天哪。
Oh, Michael. So basically what happens in the scene is that Maury is going to reveal that Stanley was also at this club with his wife and that Maury tried to wave at Stanley, but Stanley didn't wave back. Well, this is new information. Michael is thrilled. He knows something. Stanley was at a club.
哦，迈克尔。所以在这场戏里发生的事情基本上是，莫里将要透露说，斯坦利当时也和他的妻子在这个俱乐部里，而且莫里曾试图向斯坦利挥手，但斯坦利没有回挥。好吧，这是新情报。迈克尔兴奋极了。他知道了点什么。斯坦利去过俱乐部。
Yeah. Big news. Big news. Not just any club, but Tynx. Yeah. Tynx. Tynx Club. Michael would have had a talking head here that got cut.
对。大新闻。大新闻。而且不仅仅是随便什么俱乐部，而是 Tynx 俱乐部。对。Tynx。Tynx 俱乐部。迈克尔本来在这里还有一个“谈话头”镜头，不过被剪掉了。
It was in the shooting draft where he says, I know Tynx. I go there every Friday night. Well, I wait in line there. You meet a lot of fun people online. I've never been inside, but I wouldn't want. Online or in line? Sorry. Okay, sorry, sorry.
拍摄初稿里有这么一句，他说，我知道 Tynx。我每个星期五晚上都去那儿。好吧，我是在那儿排队。你在网上能认识很多有趣的人。我从没进去过，不过我也不想。是在网上还是在排队？抱歉。好吧，抱歉，抱歉。
Go ahead. Okay. You meet a lot of fun people online. I've never been inside, but I wouldn't want to. It's for people half my age. Part of me just wants to give up online dating all together. I really hate when Friday night rolls around. Wait, there's so much there.
你接着说。好吧。你在网上能认识很多有趣的人。我从没进去过，不过我也不想。那是给比我年轻一半的人去的。我有一部分甚至想彻底放弃网上交友了。每到星期五晚上，我就真的很讨厌。等等，这里信息量太大了。
He thinks online dating is you go and stand in a long line at a nightclub. Oh, my gosh. Come on. Isn't that so good? That is so good. When Maury talking about Tynx and me reading about this deleted talking head where Michael talks about Tynx, I had to know, is Tynx a real place? And by the way, it is.
他以为网上交友就是你去夜总会排很长的队。哦，天哪。拜托。这难道不是太逗了吗？这真的太逗了。当莫里谈到 Tynx，而我读到关于这个被删掉的、迈克尔谈论 Tynx 的“谈话头”时，我必须弄清楚，Tynx 是个真实存在的地方吗？顺便说一句，还真是。
It was a total hotspot, Jenna, but here's the thing. While I was researching that, I got so fascinated with the history of the building that Tynx was in. I have to share about it. I took a picture. I'll put it in stories. Look at this place, Jenna, right there in the middle. That's where Tynx would have been.
那曾经是个超级热门的聚会场所，简娜，但关键是：当我在做这方面的研究时，我对 Tynx 所在的这栋建筑的历史着迷得不行。我必须跟大家分享一下。我拍了张照片。我会把它发到快来看这个地方，简娜，就在正中间。那就是 Tynx 原本所在的位置。
This looks very, I feel like I'm looking at a picture of London. I know. It looks old, right? It looks old English to me. I found a great article on the Scranton Times Tributes website written by Brian Fulton. Brian, I loved all your info. Here's some of it. Okay.
这看起来非常……我觉得我好像在看一张伦敦的照片。我知道。它看起来很古老，对吧？我觉得它很有老英格兰的风味。我在《斯克兰顿时报论坛报》的网站上找到了一篇由布赖恩·富尔顿（Brian Fulton）撰写的精彩文章。布赖恩，我太喜欢你提供所有这些信息了。以下是其中的一部分。好吧。
The location of Tynx is 519 Linden Street in Scranton. It was constructed in 1909. It looks old. I know. It was the Courthouse Square Garage, which sold Studebakers and EFM automobiles over the years. It would be a series of dealerships that went on to be an electric appliance store, sporting goods stores.
Tynx 的地址是斯克兰顿林登街 519 号。它建于 1909 年。它看起来确实很老。我知道。它曾经是法院广场车库（Courthouse Square Garage），多年来一直在那里出售斯蒂德贝克（Studebaker）和 EFM 汽车。后来它变成了一系列汽车经销商，之后又成了电器店、体育用品店。
In the mid-20s, it became the Scranton recreation. It offered a bowling alley, a billiard room on the third floor. 30 years later, in the 50s, Renee Dress operated on the building's second floor. Even the Linden Dress Corporation bought the whole building, expanding to the third floor with retail and dining establishments on the ground floor. In 1988, it was going to have an open-air cafe, a new banquet hall that could seat 150, and the creation of a dinner theater. Oh.
在 20 世纪 20 年代中期，它变成了斯克兰顿娱乐中心（Scranton Recreation）。这里提供保龄球馆，三楼还有一个台球室。30 年代后的 50 年代，雷内服饰（Renee Dress）在这栋建筑的二楼营业。甚至连林登服饰公司（Linden Dress Corporation）都买下了整栋建筑，不仅扩展到了三楼，还在底层开设了零售店和餐饮场所。1988 年，这里计划开设一个露天咖啡馆、一个能容纳 150 人的新宴会厅，还要建立一个晚餐剧场。哦。
Yes. The first dinner theater production to take place was called Nifty 50s, a musical review. Then they started offering live music on Tuesdays and Sundays. In 1994, they sold tinks to John, Paul, and Angela Cooper, operators of Cooper Seafood House and Scranton. Oh. The venue remained a popular night spot in Scranton. It was a hub for live music for years.
对。这里上演的第一部晚餐剧场作品叫做《时髦的 50 年代》（Nifty 50s），是一场音乐歌舞 revue。后来他们开始在周二和周日提供现场音乐。1994 年，他们把 Tynx 卖给了约翰、保罗和安吉拉·库珀（John, Paul, and Angela Cooper），他们是斯克兰顿库珀海鲜屋（Cooper Seafood House）的经营者。哦。这个地方依然是斯克兰顿一个很受欢迎的夜生活场所。多年来，它一直是现场音乐的中心。
All these amazing bands would come through. And then in the fall of 2015, it became Levels on Linden, and they closed March of this year. But it started out as a car garage selling stew to bakers. I'll tell you that I got really stopped. You know, when someone's telling you a story and you hear a part of that story, and then your brain kind of goes in another place. When you said Nifty 50s musical review. You could only think of Andy Bernard.
所有这些了不起的乐队都会来这里表演。然后到了 2015 年秋天，它变成了林登阶梯（Levels on Linden），并在今年 3 月关门歇业了。但它最初竟然是一个卖斯蒂德贝克汽车的车库。我得告诉你们，我当时真的卡壳了。你知道的，当有人在给你讲故事，你听到故事的一部分，然后你的大脑就会飘到另一个地方。当你提到《时髦的 50 年代》音乐歌舞 revue 时。你只会想到安迪·伯纳德。
No. I don't think of you and I doing the Nifty 50s dinner theater musical review and what that might be. And I'm going to be honest with you, I went off on that for a while in my head. But I made it back to hear that the Cooper's people bought it. And then it was a series of nightclubs, and it closed this year. Okay. So I guess it's available.
不。我脑子里想的是你和我去做《时髦的 50 年代》晚餐剧场音乐歌舞 revue，那会是什么样。说实话，我在脑子里为这事开了好一会儿小差。但我还是回过神来，听到库珀家的人买下了它。然后它经历了一系列夜总会，并在今年关门了。好吧。所以我想它现在是空置的。
It's available! Her Angela Jena's musical theater review. I'm just saying. Oh my gosh. Nifty 50s. Nifty 50s. I mean, has anything been more made for us? Well, I just turned 50.
它是空置的！安吉拉和简娜的音乐剧院 revue。我只是随口说说。哦，天哪。《时髦的 50 年代》。《时髦的 50 年代》。我是说，还有什么比这更像是为我们量身打造的吗？好吧，我刚刚满 50 岁。
I think we wait for you to turn 50 in a few years. And then we go do the Nifty 50s. Yes. That's all I've been thinking about since you said it. I love the history of old buildings. I absolutely love it. I'd love to think about the different people that came in and out of that space. And the memories that were made, whether you were buying your very first car and it was
我想我们得等你在几年后满 50 岁。然后我们就去搞那个《时髦的 50 年代》。好啊。自从你说了之后，我脑子里就一直在想这个。我喜欢老建筑的历史。我绝对太喜欢了。我很喜欢去想象那些曾经进出过那个空间的不同人们。以及那些留下的回忆，不管你是买下了你的第一辆车——
a stew to baker, or you were doing dinner theater, or you were getting a dress made. Yes. Or you were meeting your lady love for a rendezvous, Stanley. Well when Stanley leaves the office, Michael is so excited to share what he thinks he's learned, which is that Stanley is having a midlife crisis. Because he was out at this club. But Dwight says, no, Stanley is way past the middle of his life. And Phyllis is like, Michael, what you're saying isn't true because Terry is out of
一辆斯蒂德贝克，还是去看了晚餐剧场，或者是去定制了一件衣服。是的。或者你是去和一个心上人幽会，斯坦利。好吧，当斯坦利离开办公室时，迈克尔兴奋得要命，急着分享他觉得自己打听到的消息，那就是斯坦利正在经历中年危机。因为他去了这个俱乐部。但德怀特说，不对，斯坦利的年纪早就过了中年了。而菲尔斯则说，迈克尔，你说的根本不对，因为特里不在
town and Stanley hates crowds. He hates music. He hates kids. You should check your facts. We got some Phyllis sass. Well Michael's going to march up to the interns. He's fired up. Jenna, I want you to know.
城里，而且斯坦利讨厌人多的地方。他讨厌音乐。他讨厌小孩子。你该去核实一下事实。我们迎来了菲尔斯的犀利吐槽。好吧，迈克尔要大步走向实习生们了。他现在斗志昂扬。简娜，我想让你知道。
This scene started differently in the shooting draft. Michael is still going to march up. But the interns are gossiping as he arrives. Oh. Uh-huh. It says, interior break room, Maury, Eric, and Maria, because that's what she was called in the shooting draft, are in an assembly line style, unstapling and collating and stapling. Michael barges in.
这场戏在拍摄初稿里的开场是不一样的。迈克尔依然会大步走过去。但实习生们在他到达时正在八卦。哦。嗯哼。剧本上写着，内景休息室，莫里、埃里克和玛丽亚——因为她在拍摄初稿里叫这个名字——正以流水线的方式，在起订书钉、整理文件和订订书钉。迈克尔气势汹汹地闯了进来。
Maury says, you see what Aaron's wearing today? Eric, I'm more of a Pam kind of guy. Maria, the warehouse guys were saying she's dated like everyone in the office. Oh my gosh. And then at this moment, Michael says, you stupid son of a bitch, you set me up. Well, this is when it finally occurs to Michael after much explanation that perhaps Stanley was there with someone other than his wife. The amount of time it takes Michael to clue in on something, oh my gosh, is one of my
莫里说，你看到埃隆（Aaron）今天穿的什么了吗？埃里克说，我更喜欢帕姆那款的。玛丽亚说，仓库的那帮伙计们都在说，她跟办公室里的所有人几乎都约会过。哦，天哪。然后在这个时候，迈克尔说，你这个愚蠢的混蛋，你设局陷害我。好吧，就在这个时候，经过大费周章的解释，迈克尔终于恍然大悟：或许斯坦利去那儿并不是跟他妻子在一起。迈克尔对某件事开窍需要花费的时间，哦，天哪，绝对是我最喜欢的梗之一。
favorite things. Yeah. Well, now Michael really has some gossip and he is so excited to share it. He does not at all understand the gravity of what he's sharing and the damage it could do to multiple lives. He's just giddy to have a little tidbit of info. He runs over to the biggest office gossip, Kelly, and he says Stanley's having an affair. She's like, what?
对。好吧，现在迈克尔真的掌握了一些八卦，他兴奋得迫不及待地想要分享出去。他完全没有意识到他正在分享的事情有多么严重，以及这可能会对多条人命造成多大的破坏。他只是为自己掌握了一点小八卦而兴奋得头晕目眩。他跑向办公室里最大的八卦精凯莉，然后对她说，斯坦利出轨了。而她的反应是，什么？
We had a fan catch from Sarah G in Ottawa. At around six minutes, 30 seconds, when Michael tells Kelly about Stanley's affair, there's a whiteboard behind her desk that reads people's names and numbers. It says sales, quarterly sales and HR performance. Sarah notes, one, Pam is not on there, even though she is a salesperson now, but Creed is. Sarah wants to know why is that? Sarah, I do not think that this whiteboard has been changed in like two seasons.
我们收到了来自渥太华的粉丝莎拉·G（Sarah G）的截图捉虫。在大约 6 分钟 30 秒的时候，当迈克尔告诉凯莉关于斯坦利出轨的事时，她办公桌后面有一个白板，上面写着人们的名字和数字。上面写着销售额、季度销售额和人力资源绩效。莎拉指出，第一，帕姆的名字不在上面，尽管她现在已经是个销售员了，但克里德却在上面。莎拉想知道这是为什么？莎拉，我觉得这个白板大概有两季都没换过了。
For sure. Because I remember seeing this whiteboard in season three, Andy is at the top. And I don't think I've seen this change in years. Well, to be fair, we were rarely over in that corner, so it might have gotten overlooked. Michael is determined to keep spreading this information. He is now trying to get Kevin to guess. Yes, he's playing that word guessing game hangman. Yeah.
肯定的。因为我记得我在第三季里就看到过这个白板，安迪排在最上面。而且我觉得我已经好几年没见它变过了。好吧，平心而论，我们很少去那个角落，所以它可能被忽略了。迈克尔决心继续传播这个消息。他现在正试图让凯文来猜。对，他在玩那个猜词游戏“刽子手”（Hangman）。对。
Kevin's not getting it. No. Kevin's not getting it. Lady, this reminded me of Wheel of Fortune, because Wheel of Fortune is based on this game. Oh, yeah. You guess a phrase, my family was obsessed with Wheel of Fortune. We had the home game, the Wheel of Fortune home game.
凯文没猜出来。没有。凯文没猜出来。天哪，这让我想起了《幸运轮》（Wheel of Fortune），因为《幸运轮》就是基于这个游戏改编的。哦，对。你猜一个短语，我家人以前对《幸运轮》痴迷得不行。我们有家用游戏版，《幸运轮》的家用游戏版。
And my mom, bless her heart, was a horrible guesser, just horrible. Our favorite family example. You know when you have those things that happen in your family that go down as like your family lore? Sure. Sure. Okay. We were playing this game.
而我妈妈，好心肠的妈妈，是个糟糕透顶的猜谜手，简直糟透了。我们最喜欢的家族笑料。你知道当你的家族里发生了一些事，最后变成了你们家族的传说的那种时刻吗？当然。当然。好吧。我们当时在玩这个游戏。
My mom's trying to guess the phrase. And she screams out of nowhere, I've got it. I've got it. Gold tooth tiger. Gold tooth tiger. We're like, mom, gold tooth tiger? What is this famous phrase, gold tooth tiger? I don't remember what it was.
我妈妈正在努力猜出那个短语。然后她毫无征兆地尖叫起来，我猜到了！我猜到了！金牙老虎（Gold tooth tiger）。金牙老虎。我们当时都惊了，妈，金牙老虎？这是什么著名的短语，金牙老虎？我不记得当时到底是什么了。
It was not gold tooth tiger. Of course not. So anyway, now that's like my catch phrase. Gold tooth tiger. Yeah, my sister and I can be like gold tooth tiger mom. But my sister and I became obsessed and we researched the most common letters in the English language. Wait, isn't one that you're always supposed to guess like s or t?
反正绝对不是金牙老虎。当然不是。所以不管怎样，现在这就成了我的口头禅。金牙老虎。对，我和我姐姐会说像“金牙老虎妈妈”这样的话。不过我和我姐姐后来着迷了，我们去研究了英格兰语中最常用的字母。等等，难道大家总是应该去猜的一个字母是 s 或者 t 吗？
T is one. Okay, t. I'll tell you. Here are the 12 most commonly occurring letters in the English language. From most to least, e, t, a, o, i, n, s, h, r, d, l, u. So if you're ever on Wheel of Fortune and you're going to buy a vowel by an e, if you're going to guess a consonant, the first one you should guess is t and the second one is n.
t 就是其中之一。好吧，t。我来告诉你。以下是英语中最常出现的 12 个字母。从最多到最少依次是：e, t, a, o, i, n, s, h, r, d, l, u。所以如果你哪天上了《幸运轮》，如果你要买个元音，就买 e；如果你要猜一个辅音，你第一个应该猜 t，第二个应该是 n。
I didn't know that, but I feel like some of it just mushed into my brain because my grandmother faithfully watched Wheel of Fortune every single day. It was one of her favorite shows. She was so good. She could guess way before everyone else. We used to joke, grandmother, you've got to go on Wheel of Fortune. She's like, oh no, I am not going to be on television. No.
我以前不知道这个，但我觉得这些知识有一部分直接印进了我的脑子里，因为我外祖母每天都雷打不动地看《幸运轮》。那是她最喜欢的节目之一。她可厉害了。她总是能比所有人都早猜出来。我们以前经常开玩笑说，外祖母，你得去上《幸运轮》啊。而她会说，哦不，我才不上电视呢。不。
And she loved Pat Sajak and Vanna White. They could do no wrong. Oh. And she knew everything about them. Yes, same. My family was obsessed. I love it. Just to close this out, I can also tell you the most difficult words to guess.
而且她超级喜欢帕特·萨贾克（Pat Sajak）和范娜·怀特（Vanna White）。他们俩在她眼里从来不会犯错。哦。而且她对他们的事了如指掌。是的，我也是。我家人以前也痴迷过。我太喜欢了。为了做个收尾，我还可以告诉你们最难猜的单词有哪些。
Oh, really? Yeah. This was according to a 2010 study conducted by John McLoone for Wolfram Research. Ooh. Why Wolfram Research decided to conduct the survey? I don't know. I don't know, but I appreciate it. But the five most difficult words to guess in a word guessing game are jazz, buzz, two
哦，真的吗？对。这是根据 2010 年由约翰·麦克卢恩（John McLoone）为沃尔弗拉姆研究公司（Wolfram Research）进行的一项研究得出的。噢。为什么沃尔弗拉姆研究公司会决定去做这样一个调查？我不知道。我不知道，但我很感激。不过在猜词游戏中那五个最难猜的单词是：jazz（爵士乐）、buzz（嗡嗡声），两个
Z's, hajj, fizz, and fuzz. People are not good at guessing Z words. I guess not. Yeah. I guess you can use that information if you want. Yeah. It will not help you to guess E-T-A-N-S-H-R-D-L-U. I mean, if the caption is like, hot fuzz, zhuzhing jazz, you're like, well, no one's
z，hajj（朝觐），fizz（嘶嘶声）和 fuzz（绒毛）。人们很不擅长猜带 z 的词。我想也是吧。没错。我想如果你愿意的话，你可以利用这些信息。是的。这对你靠 E-T-A-N-S-H-R-D-L-U 去猜可没什么帮助。我是说，如果字幕里出现像 hot fuzz、zhuzhing jazz 这样的词，你就会觉得，好吧，根本没人能猜得出来。没错。
going to be able to guess that. Nope. Make that your phrase. That's your gold tooth stumper. Tiger right there. That's your stumper. Michael is going to try to intercept Stanley as he's on his way to meet with a client. He asks him if he knows a beautiful woman who can dance for a movie Michael is casting.
把这个当成你的短语吧。这就是你的金牙大难题。老虎就在这儿。这就是你的绊脚石。迈克尔打算在斯坦利去见客户的路上拦截他。他问斯坦利认不认识一个会跳舞的美女，来参演一部迈克尔正在选角的电影。
It's going to pay $5 million, some nudity required. Stanley leaves and then Jim comes to the window and he's like, Michael, you need to stop. You have to stop this. You have no proof that Stanley is having an affair. You might be ruining Stanley's life. Yeah. We had a fan question, Angela, from Alice R. in Italy who said, at around seven minutes
片酬有 5 万美元，需要有一点裸露镜头。斯坦利离开后，吉姆来到窗户前说，迈克尔，你得停下来。你必须住手。你没有任何证据证明斯坦利出轨了。你可能会毁了斯坦利的生活。对。安吉拉，我们有一个来自意大利的粉丝阿莉丝·R（Alice R.）的提问，她说在大约 7 分钟
10 seconds when Michael is talking to Stanley and then Jim through the side window of his office, Aaron is sitting in the background the whole time. And then Ali W. from Canada said, is there a deleted scene that explains why Aaron is there? There isn't one on the DVDs, but I can tell you in the shooting draft at the end of this scene, Aaron had one line. What was it? As Michael considers and runs out passing by Aaron, Aaron says, is that the end of
10 秒的时候，当迈克尔在和斯坦利谈话，然后又通过他办公室的侧窗跟吉姆谈话时，埃隆（Aaron）一直坐在背景里。然后来自加拿大的阿里·W（Ali W.）说，有没有删减片段能解释为什么埃隆会在那儿？DVD 里没有这个片段，但我可以告诉你们，在拍摄初稿里，这场戏结束时，埃隆有一句台词。是什么？当迈克尔深思熟虑并跑出去、从埃隆身旁走过时，埃隆说，信就到这儿结束了吗？
the letter? Oh, so she was in there? Possibly. He was dictating a letter to her to write to someone. Ah, so good. Lady, I think we should take a break because the scene coming up when Michael runs out and gets in Stanley's car, I have a lot to say. It's so good.
哦，所以她当时真的在那儿？有可能。他当时正在口述一封信，让她写给某个人。啊，太棒了。亲爱的，我觉得我们该休息一下了，因为接下来这场戏——迈克尔跑出去坐进斯坦利的车里——我有太多话要说了。太精彩了。
It's so good. We'll be right back. Michael runs into the parking lot. He stops Stanley from driving away by throwing himself in front of Stanley's car. And then he says, are you having an affair? Cut to now he's in the car, right? And believe it or not, Stanley admits he's having an affair with Cynthia, his nurse. They had long walks on the treadmill together.
太精彩了。我们马上回来。迈克尔冲进了停车场。他用肉身挡在斯坦利的车前，阻止斯坦利开车离开。然后他说，你出轨了吗？镜头一转，现在他已经坐进车里了，对吧？信不信由你，斯坦利承认他确实和自己的护士辛西娅（Cynthia）出轨了。他们俩经常一起在跑步机上散步。
You know, Terry's been traveling so much, he's been lonely. Michael is still not getting it. But then Stanley is like, I'm actually on my way to break it off with Cynthia right now. And Michael is like, wait a second, you said you were going on a sales call, do people do that all the time? Do they tell me they're going on sales calls and they go somewhere else? Oh, Michael.
你知道的，特里经常出差，他觉得很孤单。迈克尔还是没反应过来。但接着斯坦利说，其实我现在正要去跟辛西娅分手呢。然后迈克尔就说，等等，你刚才说你要去拜访客户，大家平时都这样吗？他们会告诉我他们去见客户，结果却去了别的地方？哦，迈克尔。
And then Michael is like, wow, it's true. He finally gets it. And Stanley's like, listen, you cannot tell anyone about this, please. I'm counting on you. So in the shooting of the scene, Angela, I counted four cameras. We usually only have two cameras, but I counted four different camera angles. Get it to me, lady. Where'd you see them?
然后迈克尔说，哇，这是真的。他终于开窍了。而斯坦利则说，听着，你绝对不能把这事告诉任何人，拜托了。我指望你了。所以安吉拉，在拍摄这场戏的时候，我数了数，一共有四个摄像机。我们平时通常只有两个摄像机，但我数出了四个不同的摄像机角度。快告诉我，亲爱的。你在哪儿看到它们的？
To cover this scene. So the first one is shooting from up above, out of the office, down onto the parking lot. Then we have the bulk of the scene, which is shooting either through the window on Stanley's side or the other side shooting through the window on Michael's side. So that's three. But then for one second, right around eight minutes, 27 seconds, there is this spy shot that is straight on. And it's sort of through some leaves.
为了拍摄这场戏。所以第一个摄像机是从上往下拍，从办公室外面俯拍停车场。然后我们有全场戏的大部分镜头，也就是透过斯坦利那边的车窗拍，或者从另一边透过迈克尔那边的车窗拍。所以这是三个。但接着在短短的一秒钟内，大约在 8 分钟 27 秒的时候，有一个正对面的“偷拍”视角。而且它好像是透过一些树叶拍的。
Well, Randy told me that this was a trick. There's nothing there. Fakie tree? Fakie tree. Yes. They took a leafy branch and they put it on a grip stand. And then someone would shake it a little bit to make it seem like there was a breeze. And Matt composed his shot to include some of those leaves so that it would look like
好吧，兰迪（Randy）告诉我，这其实是个恶作剧。那里根本什么都没有。假树？假树。对。他们拿了一根长满叶子的树枝，把它固定在一个灯架（grip stand）上。然后会有人稍微晃动它一下，好让人感觉有微风吹过。而马特（Matt）构图时把其中的一些树叶拍了进去，这样它看起来就像是一个
a spy shot. Why in my brain do I hear someone like on a walkie talkie going, shake it a little less? Yeah. All right. Too much shaking. Shake it up higher. Shake it. Shake it lower.
偷拍镜头。为什么我脑子里会听到有人拿着对讲机喊：再少晃一点？对。好了。晃得太厉害了。往高处晃。晃。往低处晃。
Now, I don't know if Randy was teasing me, but he told me the technical term for this is called a branch a laurus. Come on. He said it's often used in outdoor shooting. Come on. Is that true? I don't know. Randy, a branch a laurus.
现在，我不知道兰迪是不是在逗我，但他告诉我这个术语的专业叫法是“树叶劳斯”（branch a laurus）。拜托。他说这经常用于户外拍摄。拜托。这是真的吗？我不知道。兰迪，“树叶劳斯”。
Is he listening to our podcast? He's like laughing. I bought it. Branch a laurus. So fun. If I'm ever directing Randy and I call for a branch a laurus and people don't know what I'm talking about, I'm calling you. Well, Michael is going to promise Stanley that he won't say anything, but we already
他正在听我们的播客吗？他肯定在笑。我当时真的信了。“树叶劳斯”。太搞笑了。如果我以后导演兰迪拍戏时，我要是喊一声“树叶劳斯”，而大家不知道我在说什么，我就直接给你打电话。好吧，迈克尔答应了斯坦利不会把这事说出去，但我们都已经
know it's too late for that. So now he comes up with this crazy idea that what he has to do is diffuse that one piece of information by just throwing out all kinds of rumors. Yeah. He finds Kevin in the kitchen making cookies. Yeah. He's making cookies in the toaster oven. Michael says, have you heard about Angela dating an 81-year-old billionaire who owns
知道现在说这些已经太晚了。所以他现在想出了一个疯狂的主意，那就是他必须通过抛出各种各样的谣言，来冲淡那一条真正的消息。对。他在厨房里找到了正在烤饼干的凯文。对。他正在用小烤箱烤饼干。迈克尔说，你听说安吉拉正在和一个 81 岁的亿万富翁约会、而且那个富翁还拥有一家 Quiznos（连锁三明治店）的事吗？
a quiz nose? Then he goes up to reception and he tells Aaron that Kelly is an anorexia tick. Did you notice at 10 minutes, 25 seconds, that Aaron's little desk area has a Keystone College little banner? Yes. And a teddy bear with a red hoodie. I got real interested in her reception desk, Angela. Oh, did you?
然后他走到前台，告诉埃隆（Aaron），凯莉有神经性厌食症（anorexia tick）。你有没有注意到，在 10 分钟 25 秒的时候，埃隆的小办公桌区域挂着一个小小的基斯通学院（Keystone College）横幅？对。还有一个穿着红色连帽衫的小熊。我对她的前台办公桌产生了浓厚的兴趣，安吉拉。哦，是吗？
You and I obviously were thinking the same thing because when I saw that Keystone College banner, I was like, hold up, I want to know more about Aaron. What will her desk reveal? What did you find? Well, Keystone College is a real private college in Northwestern Pennsylvania. And not only does she have a stuffed dog with a little sweater, that little sweater says J-Rob. And then she has a pink ski boot mug that she has put her pens and pencils in.
你和我显然想一块儿去了，因为当我看到那个基斯通学院的横幅时，我就想：等等，我想更多地了解一下埃隆。她的办公桌会暴露什么秘密？你发现了什么？好吧，基斯通学院是宾夕法尼亚州西北部的一所真正的私立大学。而且她不仅有一个穿着小毛衣的毛绒小狗，那件小毛衣上还写着“J-Rob”。然后她还有一个粉红色的滑雪靴马克杯，她把钢笔和铅笔都插在里面。
And that also says J-Rob. What is J-Rob? I Googled it and it is a wrestling camp in Pennsylvania. Get out. I don't think this is correct. Why they would sell a ski boot? I looked at all their merch for this wrestling camp. I don't even think the logo is the same.
那个杯子上也写着“J-Rob”。什么是“J-Rob”？我谷歌了一下，它其实是宾夕法尼亚州的一个摔跤夏令营。别开玩笑了。我觉得这不太对劲。他们怎么会卖滑雪靴形状的东西？我把这个摔跤夏令营所有的周边都看了一遍。我觉得连标志都不一样。
Did Aaron go to wrestling camp? I am very stumped on this one. I don't know. But Aaron also has a candy dish with some individually wrapped lifesavers in it. Phil Shea, what is J-Rob? What is J-Rob? And then I was like, is it J-Rububu? Like J-R-B-B?
难道埃隆去过摔跤夏令营？我对这个真的是一头雾水。我不知道。但埃隆还有一个糖果盘，里面装了一些独立包装的救生圈糖（lifesavers）。菲尔·谢，什么是“J-Rob”？什么是“J-Rob”？然后我就在想，它是 J-Rububu 吗？类似于 J-R-B-B？
Or is it J-R-O-B? I Googled both. But there is a wrestling camp in Pennsylvania called J-Rob. Okay. Michael is going to continue his rumor mill. He's going to tell Kelly that Aaron isn't a very good worker and may not last long at Dundramiflin and that Andy is gay. He tells Meredith that Pam is pregnant.
还是 J-R-O-B？这两个我都谷歌了。不过宾夕法尼亚州确实有一个叫 J-Rob 的摔跤夏令营。好吧。迈克尔要继续他的造谣机器了。他要告诉凯莉，埃隆工作表现不太好，可能在邓德米夫林（Dundler Mifflin）待不久，而且安迪是个同性恋。他告诉梅雷迪思说帕姆怀孕了。
So he's really throwing a lot of stuff out there. Of course, we know. Oh my gosh, Pam is pregnant. Yeah. Well, now the rumors are just traveling, all crazy throughout the office. Yes. And now people are going to start hearing the rumors about themselves. Yeah.
所以他真的是在到处乱放消息。当然，我们都知道。哦，天哪，帕姆怀孕了。对。好吧，现在这些谣言正在办公室里疯狂地四处传播。是的。而且现在大家开始听到关于他们自己的谣言了。对。
Andy hears this rumor that he might be gay. From Kevin and he's like, was this broccoli, Rob? Yes. Was it someone in high school? This sends Andy on an existential crisis and he's going to confront Oscar in the break room. Oscar has such a great talking head after that scene with Andy where he's like, what is my responsibility to comfort the insecure heterosexual men that can't possibly fall
安迪听到了关于他可能是同性恋的谣言。从凯文那里听来的，然后他说，这该不会是西兰花罗布（Broccoli Rob）说的吧？对。难道是高中时期的某个人？这让安迪陷入了存在主义危机，他要去找奥斯卡在休息室对质。奥斯卡在那场和安迪的对手戏之后有一个非常棒的“谈话头”镜头，他说，我去安慰那些根本不可能把责任推到我头上的、缺乏安全感的异性恋男人，这难道是我的责任吗？
on me. I'm paraphrasing it, but it's something like that. It's so good. When Andy is describing this scenario where Brad Pitt is like coming onto him at like a beach cabana. Yes. And Brad Pitt is trying to kiss him and Andy resists, but Brad Pitt keeps coming for him. Oscar has this amazing line where he says, so if you resisted Brad Pitt a little bit,
我是意译的，但大概就是这么个意思。太精彩了。当安迪描述那个布拉德·皮特在海滩小屋里对展开追求的场景时。对。然后布拉德·皮特试图吻他，而安迪反抗了，但布拉德·皮特一直对穷追不舍。奥斯卡有一句绝妙的台词，他说：所以如果你稍微反抗了一下布拉德·皮特，
he would still need to get to you. Lady, the mention of Brad Pitt made me very randomly think about how I have had recurring dreams about Brad Pitt making me soup. What? He makes me soup. What does this mean? Recurring dream. Like over your life?
他还是会想对你下手。亲爱的，提到布拉德·皮特，让我非常随机地想到了我曾经做过关于布拉德·皮特给我做汤的反复出现的梦。什么？他给我做汤。这代表什么意思？反复出现的梦。就像贯穿你的整个人生？
Yes. Like since college. What? And Brad Pitt would make me a warm, comforting bowl of soup and it would make me happy and he was my friend in my dreams. Was he fully clothed? Yes. Okay.
对。从大学开始就这样。什么？然后布拉德·皮特会给我做一碗温暖、治愈的汤，这会让我很开心，而且在我的梦里他是我的朋友。他穿好衣服了吗？对。
It was just a wonderful gesture. So I looked up, you know, dreams and meaning of dreams. What does it mean if you have soup in your dream? Well, what a celebrity in your dream is, is that the celebrity is you. It's like a version of you. So you are Brad Pitt and you're making yourself soup? I guess so, but more than that, here's what I determined it to be. Okay.
这只是一个非常暖心的举动。所以我去查了查，你知道的，梦境与梦的解析。如果在梦里梦见汤意味着什么？好吧，梦里的名人其实代表着你自己。就像是另一个版本的你自己。所以你自己就是布拉德·皮特，然后你在给自己做汤？我猜是的，但不仅如此，我是这样解读它的：
Brad Pitt is from Missouri. He's from where I grew up. So I think he was the big local celebrity when you were growing up. He went to Mizzou, which was the college about an hour and a half away from my college. He didn't finish, but then he went off and he became a big star. You know, I've never met him. I've never been able to geek out with him about our Missouri roots, but it was a big deal.
布拉德·皮特来自密苏里州。他来自我长大的地方。所以我认为他是你成长时期的本地大明星。他去上了密苏里大学（Mizzou），那是离我的大学大约一个半小时车程的学校。他没读完，但后来他离开了，成了一个大明星。你知道的，我从来没见过他。我从来没有机会跟他狂热地聊聊我们密苏里州的根，但这绝对是一件大事。
Like when you're from Missouri and someone else from Missouri is super famous, like everybody knows it, you know? Oh man, I can never meet him now. Why? Because I know me. You're going to say something. And I know if I meet Brad Pitt, yeah, I won't be able to. It'll be like a Michael Scott moment.
就像当你来自密苏里州，而另一个来自密苏里州的人超级有名时，每个人都知道，对吧？哦天哪，我现在永远不能见他了。为什么？因为我太了解我自己了。你会说漏嘴的。我知道如果我见到布拉德·皮特，是的，我根本把持不住。那绝对会是一个迈克尔·斯科特式的时刻。
I'll say, my fringe and dreams that you make her soup. It'll just come tumbling out. I can never meet him. How can I ever meet him now when I know that my best friend since college has dreamed that he makes her soup? Here's what I think it is. I think he represents like whenever I felt homesick, I'll have a dream where like my hometown is making me soup.
我会说：“我在梦里梦到你给我做汤。”这些话就会直接脱口而出。我永远不能见他了。当我知道我从大学起最好的朋友一直梦到他给她做汤之后，我怎么还能去见他呢？我觉得是这样的。我觉得他代表着——每当我感到想家的时候，我就会做一个家乡正在给我做汤的梦。
Like that's what I think it is. I think it's like a homesickness dream. I have never had a dream about Brad Pitt. Well, his soup is delicious. I just want to say it's homemade and it's very, very good. And it's always, the soup is different. It's been, I remember very distinctly, there was a vegetable and another time a crema potato. I had a dream after I saw the Matrix that I could, you know, that I was like a badass
我觉得大概就是这种感觉。我觉得这就是一个思乡之情的梦。我从来没做过关于布拉德·皮特的梦。好吧，他的汤真的很美味。我只想说那是自制的，而且非常好喝。而且汤总是——我记得非常清楚，有一次是蔬菜汤，还有一次是土豆奶油汤。我看过《黑客帝国》之后做过一个梦，梦见自己（你知道的）和一个硬汉基努一起成为了狠角色。
with Keanu. And I was like, I could do all that stuff like I could fly a helicopter. Not quite the same. It's not quite the same. I don't know what that means. And I also have never had it again. I don't know. I haven't had this dream in a long time.
而且我觉得我能做到所有那些事，就像我能开直升机一样。这可完全不一样。这完全不是一码事。我不知道那意味着什么。而且我也再没做过那种梦了。不知道。我好久没做过这个梦了。
Amazing. Amazing. Where were we? I don't know. It doesn't matter anymore. Brad Pitt makes you soup. Okay. We are at the point where now rumors are really spreading.
太神奇了。太神奇了。我们刚才聊到哪儿了？我不知道。这已经不重要了。布拉德·皮特给你做汤。好吧。我们现在说到谣言正在疯狂传播的节点了。
Oh, here we are. I know where we are. We're in the conference room and we're giving the interns their letters of completion and they're going to get some school credit. And there's cake. Fan catch from Sophia M. from Louisiana, Dwight is handing the interns a piece of paper to give them school credit, but in job fair, Michael says they cannot offer credit. Can you explain this?
哦，我们到这儿了。我知道我们到哪儿了。我们在会议室里，正在给实习生们颁发结业证书，他们能拿到一些学校学分。还有蛋糕。来自路易斯安那州的索菲亚·M（Sophia M.）的粉丝捉虫，德怀特正在给实习生们一张纸来帮他们获取学校学分，但在“招聘会”（Job Fair）那一集里，迈克尔却说他们无法提供学分。你能解释一下吗？
Sophia, I cannot explain it. I don't know. Maybe once Michael put Dwight in charge of it, it actually got done. Perhaps. I love that Dwight gives them his business card. He says, you can call me day or night, and then one of the interns says, why would I call you at night? Eric does.
索菲亚，我无法解释。我不知道。也许一旦迈克尔让德怀特负责这件事，它居然真的办成了。有可能吧。我喜欢德怀特把自己的名片给他们的那个情节。他说，你们日夜都可以打电话给我，然后其中一个实习生说，我为什么要在晚上打电话给你？埃里克说的。
Yeah. And then he says, no, you can't call me at all. And Jim's like, well, good luck next time you're stuck between a moose and a bear. Between a moose and her cubs. Oh, and her cubs. Well, the rumors are coming out because people start commenting. For example, Erin says to Kelly, I'm so happy you're eating again. Yeah.
对。然后德怀特说，不，你们什么时间都不能打电话给我。而吉姆则说，好吧，祝你们下次被困在驼鹿和熊之间时好运。在驼鹿和它的幼崽之间。哦，还有它的幼崽。好吧，谣言开始浮出水面了，因为大家开始互相议论了。比如，埃隆对凯莉说，我真高兴你又开始吃东西了。对。
And then Andy congratulates Jim on little baby tuna. Little Toro. Jim pulls Pam aside and he's like, they know. I don't know how they know, but they know. This brings us to my favorite line of the show. What is it? Is it? I know what it is.
然后安迪祝贺吉姆喜得“小金枪鱼”。小托罗（Toro）。吉姆把帕姆拉到一边说，他们知道了。我不知道他们是怎么知道的，但他们全知道了。这让我们迎来了全剧我最喜欢的台词。是什么？是吗？我知道是什么。
When Creed says someone is saying the rumor about Creed is that he has asthma. Yeah. And if that gets out, they're not going to let him scuba. And he has a talking head where he says, if he can't scuba, then what has all of this been about? What has he been working toward? I love it so much. I love the scuba talking head.
当克里德说，有关于他的谣言是说他有哮喘。对。如果这个传出去，他们就不会让他去潜水（scuba）了。然后他有一个“谈话头”镜头，他说，如果他不能去潜水，那这一切到底是为了什么？他这一直以来都在为了什么努力？我太喜欢了。我太喜欢潜水那个“谈话头”了。
I'm pretty sure I remember John breaking though when Creed said, they won't let me scuba. Just Creed saying the word scuba. I would like to point out one thing in this scene. Many of you probably didn't catch it unless you've ever had a really horrible time growing out your bangs. If you go to 15 minutes oh seven, you'll see my hair awkwardly trying to be a ponytail, but it can't really be a ponytail because I decided to get bangs and it took forever to grow them out.
我挺确定我记得当克里德说“他们不会让我去潜水”时，约翰（John）其实笑场了。光是克里德说出“潜水（scuba）”这个词就够好笑了。我想在这场戏里指出一件事。你们很多人可能都没注意到，除非你也经历过刘海尴尬期那段非常痛苦的时光。如果你跳到 15 分钟零 7 秒，你会看到我的头发在极其尴尬地试图扎成一个马尾，但它其实根本扎不成马尾，因为我当时决定去剪刘海，而它们要花好长时间才能长长。
Look at this sad ponytail. I mean, I have to say that looks like Pam's hair from seasons one through three. The little swoop that we used to do with my half bangs is what that reminds me of. Oh bangs. Well, Oscar wants everyone to know he is not the voice of the Taco Bell dog. Toby is not a virgin. The conference room is a buzz. Everyone is trading rumors about themselves.
看看这个伤心的马尾辫。我是说，我得承认那看起来就像帕姆在第一季到第三季的发型。我们以前用半长不短的刘海做的那种小刘海弧（swoop），就是那个感觉。哦，刘海。好吧，奥斯卡想让所有人知道他并不是塔可钟（Taco Bell）那只狗的配音。托比并不是个处男。会议室里一片沸腾。每个人都在互相交易关于自己的谣言。
Jim is like, guys, has everybody heard a crazy rumor about themselves today? And Michael is like, you know what, let's just forget all of them. Well they start tracing it all back. And guess where every rumor came from? Mm-hmm. Michael. Who runs to the elevator because he knows. But the entire gang stops him, confronts him, Dwight cannot believe that he told people
吉姆说，伙计们，今天有人听到关于他们自己的疯狂谣言吗？而迈克尔则说，你知道吗，咱们干脆把这些全忘了吧。好吧，他们开始顺藤摸瓜地追查源头。你猜每个谣言都是从哪儿传出来的？嗯哼。迈克尔。他拼命逃向电梯，因为他知道自己露馅了。但整个办公室的人都拦住他、跟他当面对质，德怀特简直不敢相信迈克尔竟然告诉别人
that Shroot Farms uses store-bought manure when Dwight showed Michael where his manure comes from. Oh my gosh. Eventually, Michael is going to admit that he started the rumors. I actually love that Michael's like, hey, I'm a victim here too. I mean, people were saying I was a J crew model. Exactly. But Michael says he had to start all the rumors because one of the rumors is true.
舒鲁特农场使用的是买来的现成肥料，明明德怀特带迈克尔亲自看过他的肥料是怎么来的。哦，天哪。最终，迈克尔承认了那些谣言都是他自己挑起的。其实我挺喜欢迈克尔说“嘿，我也是个受害者啊”。我是说，大家之前还在说我是 J.Crew 的模特呢。没错。但迈克尔说他必须散布所有的谣言，因为其中有一个谣言是真的。
He's not going to say which one. He starts going around and Jim and Pam realize pretty quickly what the real rumor is. Yeah. That Stanley's having an affair. But everyone's insisting that Michael say what the real rumor is and he's about to reveal that. So Jim jumps in and says, the real thing is that Pam is pregnant. And right away, Angel's like, I knew it.
他打死不说到底是哪一个。他开始在人群中转悠，而吉姆和帕姆很快就意识到真正的谣言是什么了。对。就是斯坦利出轨了。但每个人都坚持要迈克尔说出哪个才是真正的谣言，而他正准备把这个秘密抖出来。所以吉姆挺身而出说，真正的事实是帕姆怀孕了。紧接着，安吉拉就说，我就知道。
I know. And Kevin is like, I knew it because Pam's boobs were bigger. Boobs, boobs, boobs. And Jim's like, okay, buddy, okay. We had a fan question from Renata P. from Rio de Janeiro, Brazil. What are your thoughts about Jim's revelation to the whole office that the rumor about Pam being pregnant was actually true? I know he was trying to protect Stanley and it never really bothered me before.
我知道。而凯文则说，我早就知道了，因为帕姆的胸变大了。胸，胸，胸。而吉姆则说，行了，老兄，行了。我们收到了来自巴西里约热内卢的雷娜塔·P（Renata P.）的粉丝提问。你对吉姆向整个办公室透露帕姆怀孕的谣言其实是真的这件事有什么看法？我知道他是为了保护斯坦利，而且我以前从没觉得这有什么问题。
But in re-watching the scene yesterday, I was like, hey, maybe he should have had a conversation with Pam before telling everyone, what do we think? I actually think Pam and Jim were on the same page in this moment because the way Pam's body language was and your dialogue, it's like the two of you both knew, oh no, oh no. He's about to destroy Stanley's life. Oh no, we've got to do something. I felt like I saw that internal dialogue between the two of you. Well, I'm glad to hear you say that, Angela, because that was our intention.
但昨天重看这场戏时，我在想：嘿，也许他在告诉大家之前应该先跟帕姆商量一下，我们怎么看？其实我觉得帕姆和吉姆在那一刻是心意相通的，因为看帕姆当时的肢体语言还有你的台词，你们俩当时都意识到了一件事：哦不，哦不。他要毁了斯坦利的生活。哦不，我们得做点什么。我觉得我看到了你们俩之间那种无声的内心对话。好吧，很高兴听到你这么说，安吉拉，因为这正是我们的本意。
The intention was that Jim and Pam were going to both come to this realization. And this is like they share a brain thing. They're a couple. And so... Couple. It's a couple brain. Couple brain. So I totally get where Renata is coming from.
我们的本意是吉姆和帕姆会同时意识到这一点。这就像是他们俩共用一个大脑。他们是一对情侣。所以……情侣。这就是“情侣大脑”。情侣大脑。所以非常理解雷娜塔的感受。
Our hope was that you would see Pam's permission in that moment in the way we... Her participation in the moment. And how we're sort of giving each other eye contact was our intention. Of course, Michael, though, is like, no, no, no, that's not it. And you guys are like, oh, will you stop it? Like just like, oh. So she has to go out and get her sonogram photo. One of my favorite things is when you go get your sonogram photo is that Kelly says, or
我们的愿望是，你能在那个瞬间从我们的表演中看出帕姆的许可——她对那一刻的参与感。以及我们如何通过眼神交流来表达这一点，这正是我们的意图。当然，迈克尔的反应却是，不，不，不，根本不是这回事，而你们俩的反应则是，拜托你能闭嘴吗？就像那种“噢”的感觉。所以她不得不出去把自己的B超照片拿来。我最喜欢的情节之一，就是当你去拿B超照片时，凯莉说：还是说我们大家都要在这儿等着？那是明迪（Mindy）自己发挥的。那完全是明迪。好吧，我们收到了来自英国的埃拉·R（Ella R.）的粉丝提问，帕姆的B超照片是真的吗？如果不是，它是怎么制作出来的？好问题。我们的平面设计师雷恩·科斯格罗夫（Ryan Cosgrove），这是他为我们制作的。他借用了他朋友妻子的现成B超照片。
we're just all going to wait here. That was just Mindy. That was just Mindy. Well, we had a fan question from Ella R in England, is Pam's sonogram real? And if not, how was it created? Good question. Our graphic artist, Ryan Cosgrove, he made this for us. He repurposed an existing sonogram from his friend's wife.
哦。所以在这个世界的某个地方，有一个小宝宝，一个获得过出镜时间的可爱小宝宝。好吧，当帕姆展示她的B超照片时，迈克尔说：那是她阴道内部的照片。对。那是一张她阴道内部的照片。紧接着是一个吉姆和帕姆的“谈话头”镜头，他们俩的表情仿佛在说：呃-哼，现在清楚了吧。很清楚为什么我们不想把这事告诉这群人了。
Oh. So somewhere out there, there's a little baby, a little baby who got some screen time. Yeah. Well, when Pam presents her sonogram, Michael says, that's the inside of her vagina. Yeah. That's a picture of the inside of her vagina. Very quickly, Jim and Pam talking head where they're like, uh-huh, now it's clear. It's clear why we didn't want to tell these people.
好吧，现在吉姆和帕姆就像是被叫去了校长办公室。迈克尔感到痛心疾首，因为他们没有第一时间告诉他，也没有更早地告诉他。他们居然只告诉了各自的父母。在拍摄初稿里，台词原本是这样的：“你朝一根验孕棒上尿了吗？”我猜在拍摄当天他们把它改成了“P”开头的缩写（Pee）。但当我读到拍摄初稿里的那句台词时，觉得太刺耳了。我想：他怎么会说“你朝一根验孕棒上尿了吗”？好吧，迈克尔这回可闯大祸了，伙计们。
Well now Jim and Pam are going to be like in the principal's office. Michael is devastated that they did not tell him first, that they did not tell him sooner. They only just told their parents in the shooting draft, the line read like this, did you piss on a stick? And I guess on the day they changed it to P. But when I read that in the shooting draft, it was so jarring. I'm like, why would he say, did you piss on a stick? Well Michael has done something guys.
现在吉姆和帕姆就像是要去校长办公室一样。迈克尔非常伤心，因为他们没有先告诉他，也没有早点告诉他。在拍摄剧本中，他们只是刚刚告诉了父母，台词是这样的：你用验孕棒测过了吗？我猜在拍摄当天他们把它改成了测孕纸。但当我在拍摄剧本中读到这一句时，感觉太刺耳了。我想，他怎么会说出“你用验孕棒测过了吗”这种话呢？好吧，各位，迈克尔做出了一些举动。
He has called Stanley's wife. This scene is so brilliant. When Aaron says Terry Hudson's on the line, you guys, your faces are like, you called her? And Michael's like, I got this. I can do it. I'll tell her I'm redecorating my condo. And they're like, no, Michael, don't, you guys are like, don't, don't, but he has this
他给斯坦利的妻子打了电话。这个场面太精彩了。当亚伦说特里·哈德森在线时，你们的表情就像是，你给她打电话了？迈克尔则是一副“我搞得定，我能行，我告诉她我在重新装修公寓”的样子。而你们却在说，不，迈克尔，别这样，你们就像是在劝他别打、别打，但他却有一整套
whole thing. It's going to have to play out over months where he's redecorating the condo. They're going to get quotes, but then they're going to get an argument about the cost of things. And eventually he's just going to have to call it all off. And he literally is like, I've got this. And Pam is like, Michael, please don't. Michael picks up the phone and says, hey, what up, Cynthia?
说辞。这件事得花上好几个月的时间来推进，说他正在重新装修公寓。他们会拿到报价，然后会因为东西的费用争吵起来。最后他只能把这一切都取消。而他真的就像是“我能搞定”。帕姆则说，迈克尔，求你别打了。迈克尔拿起电话说，嘿，辛西娅，最近怎么样？
I mean, just amazing. Jim starts to walk over and Michael is waving him off like, I got it. I got it. And then he goes, hold on a second, Cynthia, and then Jim just hangs up the phone. We had a fan question from Kelsey S. from Chandler, Arizona, who says, this is my absolute favorite episode of all time. This is my comfort episode. I watch it all of the time.
我是说，简直绝了。吉姆开始走过去，迈克尔挥手让他别过来，意思是交给我，我来搞定。然后他说，等一下，辛西娅，接着吉姆直接把电话挂了。我们收到了来自亚利桑那州钱德勒市 Kelsey S. 的粉丝提问，她说，这是我历年来绝对最喜欢的一集。这是我的治愈系单集，我经常看。
And I need to know if the scene where Michael answers the call from Terry, was it all improvised or was it scripted? Everything from Steve's reaction to his hand movements on the phone is hilarious. And I love it. This entire scene played out exactly as scripted. Minus the piss. That's the only thing that changed. It is 100% on the page.
我想知道迈克尔接听特里电话的那场戏，是全部即兴发挥的还是剧本写好的？从史蒂夫的反应到他在电话上的手部动作，所有的一切都超级搞笑，我太喜欢了。整场戏完全是按剧本演的。除了那个“尿”的桥段，那是唯一改动的地方。这百分之百是剧本里写好的。
Guess what? Terry was already suspicious about this affair. And this, I guess, proves it. Stanley is going to vandalize Michael's car. Stanley takes a crowbar to Michael's car and destroys it. We had a couple of fan questions about this. Then from Rohit R. in Norman, Oklahoma, how much did the scene of Stanley smashing Michael's car cost?
你猜怎么着？特里之前就对这段外遇有所怀疑了。我想，这下证据确凿了。斯坦利要去破坏迈克尔的车。斯坦利拿着撬棍砸了迈克尔的车，把它彻底砸毁了。我们收到了一些关于这个场景的粉丝提问。来自俄克拉何马州诺曼市的 Rohit R. 问，砸毁迈克尔车的那场戏花了不少钱吧？
And Monica F. from North Carolina said, it's so funny to me that Stanley had enough time to put on his sunglasses before smashing Michael's car. Well, guys, Leslie did the smashing. Randy said he had a very good time. I would, too. I would, too. He said that they had to establish him wearing the sunglasses earlier in the episode so that during this scene, he would have eye protection in case anything flew up in his eyes.
北卡罗来纳州的 Monica F. 说，我觉得特别搞笑的是，斯坦利在砸迈克尔的车之前，竟然还有时间戴上太阳镜。好吧，各位，砸车是莱斯利（Leslie）干的。兰迪（Randy）说他玩得很开心。换作我也会的，我也会的。他说他们必须在剧集早些时候安排他戴上太阳镜，这样在这场戏里，万一有什么东西飞进眼睛里，他就能得到眼部保护。
Randy said he smashed the heck out of that car. It was a one-er, just one take. It cost over $4,000 to repair. I don't doubt it. When he called up and started to mess with the convertible top, I was like, oh, no. That's some cha-ching. Well, guys, that's basically the end of this episode. The interns have a little talking head at the end where we find out that Michael just
兰迪说他把那辆车砸得稀巴烂。这是一条过，只拍了一次。修复费用超过了4000美元。我对此深信不疑。当他打电话过去并开始对敞篷车顶动手脚时，我就想，噢不，这可得花一大笔钱。好吧，各位，这基本上就是这一集的内容了。实习生们在最后有一个简短的访谈，我们发现迈克尔刚刚
called them Jet Lee, Julia Stiles, and Alan Thicke. And that Eric never really learned how many pieces of paper were in a room of paper. In the very end credits at 21 minutes 34 seconds, Randy Cordray pointed something out to us, and I want to share it to you. We see the name of our new unit production manager for season six, Steve Burgess. Steve was a very old and dear friend of Randy, and I loved Steve Burgess so much. He went on to be our line producer in the last seasons. We adore him, and it was so fun to finally see his name.
管他们叫李连杰、朱丽娅·斯蒂尔斯和阿兰·锡克。而且埃里克从来没有真正弄清楚一包纸里到底有多少张纸。在片尾字幕21分34秒处，兰迪·科德雷（Randy Cordray）向我们指出了一个细节，我想跟你们分享。我们看到了第六季新任制片主任的名字，史蒂夫·伯吉斯（Steve Burgess）。史蒂夫是兰迪非常老也非常亲爱的朋友，我太喜欢史蒂夫·伯吉斯了。他在后面的几季中担任了我们的制片经理。我们非常喜欢他，最终看到他的名字出现在屏幕上真的很有趣。
Randy said when he brought him on board that Steve's contributions behind the scenes were immeasurable. Yes, and we are still in touch with Steve today. So when we get to those episodes where he was the line producer, we're going to get to hear from him. Yay. Well, that's gossip. Do you think I'll end up in the gossip magazines because of my soup dreams with Brad Pitt?
兰迪说，当他把史蒂夫招进团队时，史蒂夫在幕后的贡献是不可估量的。是的，直到今天我们和史蒂夫仍然保持着联系。所以当我们播到他担任制片经理的那些集数时，我们就能听到他的声音了。太棒了。好了，这就是八卦。你觉得我会因为和布拉德·皮特的汤梦而登上八卦杂志吗？
Would that be so weird? That would be such a full circle moment. I know. Who's going to write about it? I don't know. Maybe no one. No one cares about my soup. Your fake soup?
那会很奇怪吗？那将是一个完美的闭环。我知道。谁会写这个呢？我不知道。也许没人吧。没人关心我的汤。你的假汤？
My fake soup! With Brad Pitt! Listen, if we ever hear from Brad Pitt about the fake soup, I will be so excited. If we ever hear from Brad Pitt, what if one day, what if one day, I'm sorry, I'm having a dream. And I'm so sorry for anyone listening, I probably then scared you. What if one day, we are doing office ladies and we get some soup delivered and it's from Brad Pitt.
我的假汤！和布拉德·皮特一起的！听着，如果我们有一天真的从布拉德·皮特那里听到关于假汤的消息，我会兴奋死的。如果我们收到布拉德·皮特的消息，万一有一天，万一有一天，抱歉，我在做梦。对于所有正在听节目的听众我感到非常抱歉，我可能刚才把你们吓到了。万一有一天，我们正在录制 Office Ladies，然后有人送来了一碗汤，而且是布拉德·皮特送的。
Come on. Could that happen? And you know what? Guess who's going to deliver it? Keanu. If Keanu Reeves delivered soup made by Brad Pitt. And then all of a sudden Idris Elba is going to like bring some music into it and we're going to just have like a soup eating party.
拜托。这可能发生吗？你知道吗？你猜是谁送来的？基努。如果基努·里维斯送来了布拉德·皮特做的汤。然后突然之间伊德里斯·艾尔巴要加点音乐进来，我们就只是开一个喝汤派对。
What has just happened? I don't know. Well, save it for nifty fifties. A musical review. And you guys, we hope you have a fantastic week. Once again, thank you to Randy Cordray, Max Carver, and all of you guys for sending in your questions and your comments. We hope you have a great week.
刚刚发生什么了？我不知道。好吧，留着去“俏丽五十年代”音乐剧评论里用吧。各位，我们希望你们度过愉快的一周。再次感谢兰迪·科德雷、马斯·卡弗以及所有发来问题和评论的听众。祝大家过得愉快。
We love you. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com.
我们爱你们。感谢收听 Office Ladies。Office Ladies 由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的助理制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是里德·勃拉特（Creed Bratton）的《橡树》。要收听无广告版本的 Office Ladies，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。
For a free one month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在 Stitcher Premium 注册即可免费试用一个月，使用优惠码 OFFICE。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。